e
the H will come to order members take
your seats
the chair recognizes a member from
Auburn representative Osborne who moves
the house a Jour from the session of
March 28th 2024 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the house is adjourned the house will
attend to a Prayer by the member from
Hamstead The Honorable Mark
Pearson would you pray with me
please Almighty all wise and all loving
one you gave to your servant King David
many Psalms one of which Begins the
heavens declare the glory of God and the
firmament shows his
handiwork oh God just a few days ago we
saw your glory in the sky and as we look
around us we see day by day your glory
in
creation Inspire us to be be good
stewards of that
creation we also ask your presence your
guiding hand upon us and your grace
working in us as we do the work set
before us as a
legislature so many of us grieve as we
see in so many places what the political
process has become Deliver Us from that
oh God and remind us that the same Psalm
which began with the heavens giving you
glory and ends with a prayer that by
your grace each of us can be better and
each of us can do better David ended by
saying let the words of my mouth and the
meditation of my heart be acceptable in
your sight oh Lord my strength and my
redeemer oh God may this be so amen
am Jer recogniz a member from Peter bro
represent of Peter leechman who will
lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance
flag
States
indice the chair recognizes the Sea
Coast men of Harmony who will now sing
our national anthem
e
[Music]
the
flag
still
[Music]
and
the
[Music]
[Applause]
of
yeah
the house will attend to a request for
leaves of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives cert sfus and trevan the
day important business Representatives
Harley Judy O'Hara St Clair and Tetro
the day illness in the family
representative
sandborn these leaves of option shall be
granted L otherwise ordered by the house
the house will attend to the
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome Anna Camden and Abigail Bates s
Sally Sarah Jill and Luca Varney and
Jackson Brock guests of Representative
Woodcock Taylor odonovan Rihanna Emer
vones and Susan Mohler guests of
Representative tensar and Jenna Karen
Guest of Representative Damon they are
with us in the gallery
today welcome to the the Hampshire
house
[Applause]
the house will now attend to Memorial
remarks for a member from conquered the
honorable Arthur Ellison the chair
recognizes representative
Miler thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to
invite down to be behind me those who
knew art and who worked with
him Anna and Sally and family welcome to
the house the people's
house I had the
pleasure of being with art the night
before he
passed
and these are the words that came to me
as I got home and I'd like to share them
with
you art is
gone his life's journey has
ended he was a fighter and gave so much
to
others I've only known art in his
legislative years but have come to
respect his life as he served others in
his
life he came to the house education
committee with 38 years of service in
the adult education community Through
the Department of
Education he enabled those adults who
had given up on themselves a second
chance a second chance to better their
lives he told me that all he wanted to
do was to give voice to the
voiceless and just think of the
thousands of lives he touched which gave
them a chance to be their better
selves in talk about feeding
kids he was a master
Advocate when he got knocked down on a
vote in this house he did not coward to
the opposition oh no he came at them
again and again saying just feed the
kids he was a fighter and an advocate
for the
underdog for two years art struggled
with
self he finally relented to getting a
handicapped parking spot at the
insistence of the house Democrat
education
members he moved from hospital to
hospital trying to cure his heart and
lung
issues and then a month ago he called me
and said Mel it's time for me to throw
in the towel I said whatat do you mean
Ard the doctors have informed me that
there's nothing more that they can do
for me I just want to come home and be
with my
friends so home he
came he came not to an isolated dark
room but to a bright room at the vage
hospice
center and when the word got out that he
was in hospice the parade started his
friends his colleagues his teammates
they came to celebrate his life it was
an opportunity to share stories
experiences and life with those who came
to bid their final farewells to him to a
guy who gave so
much and in him exposing himself to
others his smile his humor his Spirit he
gave us all a gift on how to die with
dignity this was his lasting gift to
me
celebrate celebrate your life with
others invite them in engage them laugh
cry hold their hands
hugs as he did in his life with others
he gave voice to us to be with
him as we enter this life passage with
art
we obviously challenge our own
mortality we know that there are only
two certain things in life and that is
that we die we are born and we
die the question is is what do we do
between those two life
events the last time I was with
art he was in his last deep
sleep I have held his warm
hand and told him of the life that he
made a difference in
others and as I
talked his shallow breathing became
deeper and I could feel that he heard my
voice in the acknowledgment of his
life's
accomplishments there will surely be
regrets I didn't spend enough time what
more could I have done we had unfinished
business I didn't have a chance to shoot
hoops with
him but he would say move
on he would say don't dwell on the
current but always move
forward the Buddhist faith has the
belief in the concept of
impermanence that life is Ever
Changing life is always moving it never
stays stays the
same we are in that
moment we can be sad and we can share
the loss of art
Ellison but he would say come on come on
now let's move
on the sorrow of the moment will soon be
replaced by the fond memories of the
past so let's remember art for his
contributions to others to our own life
but move quickly
for what art would say right now would
be fight on never give up oh yeah just
feed the damn kids thank you Mr Speaker
we all raise for a moment of silence for
our fallen
call
without objection the the comments will
be printed in the permanent
Journal chair recognizes a member from
ringe representative John Hunt for the
purpose of Titan day
ceremony thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker incredibly this is
the
27th anniversary of the New Year
Hampshire's house
celebrating Tartan day when our former
colleague the late Representative Steve
Avery of Dublin first led this ceremony
in
1997 most in this chamber were not yet
Representatives some of you weren't even
born
yet however this day has become not only
a symbol of honoring a great people but
has become a historical part of our
house tradition and one in which many of
you come to look forward to to so we're
back April 6th is Tartan day adopted by
the president Congress and our governor
and marks the day the decoration of arbo
was signed in
1320 which was the Declaration of
Scottish independence from
Britain this document was credited as a
model for our own Declaration of
Independence and perhaps one of the most
important lessons from this document is
this quote
it is in truth not for
Glory nor riches nor Honors that we are
fighting but for freedom for that alone
which no honest man gives up but with
life
itself the Scots have pioneered uh in
many ways in our civilization Alexander
granbell with the telephone Alexander
Fleming discovering penicil penicil
Adam Smith founding political economics
Arthur Corin Doyle with his mystery
Nolla John Paul Jones with his modern
Naval tactics John mure creating the US
National Park system and of course Sean
connory as James Bond today would not be
possible without groups like our friends
at the New Hampshire Scott who have
organized this widely popular Highland
Games every year since
1976 and our our friends at the Scottish
Arts Scottish Arts has been achieve
notable success as solo competitors at
very levels in the fields of piping
fiddling and even dancing well with that
Mr Speaker please join with me and
welcoming the Fiddlers of the Mariel
Webster and Samuel stalker and Pipers
William Todd Matthew schotman James Fox
Callum stalker and of course the
original pipe major Campbell Webster as
they perform for
[Applause]
[Music]
us
[Applause]
[Music]
w today would not be possible without
groups like our friends of the New
Hampshire Scott who have organized
wildely already did that
oh before we entertain with more music I
like all of those who have with tarton
today who wore their Tartan today to
please rise and be
recognized so all of you have some
Tartan look at that
awesome
thank you for wearing
him
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
w
[Music]
for
[Applause]
l
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Speaker we now arrive at the solemn
part of our ceremony where as we have in
the past we remember and pay tribute to
our departed house colleagues who passed
away uh this session please rise as we
honor those Among Us who have passed in
our special way representative Roger
mener Sharon norgren and Arthur
[Music]
Ellison
thank you Mr Speaker and with the
members please be
seated I'll now like to uh invite the
house clerk with a
Grace with special Scottish blessing
bless this house and those within bless
our giving and receiving bless our words
and
conversation bless our hands and
Recreation bless our sewing and our
growing bless our coming and our going
bless all who enter and depart bless
this house your peace
impart
[Music]
Mr Speaker members of the House thank
you for your attention today as we
celebrate this wonderful event once
again I'd like to tr thank our friends
at the Scottish Arts in New Hampshire
Scott we're grateful for your attention
today so until we meet on the Bonnie
Bonnie Banks of L Lon may your days be
long and that thistles in front of you
bright this concludes
[Applause]
our for what reason the member rise
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I may I
first ask if the remarks of our good
friend from ring be placed in the perent
journal and may also point out Mr
Speaker that some of us are wearing the
Irish National quilt today that is the
Plaid of the quilt that was wrapped
around the body of General Michael
Collins when he was killed in B naath in
August of
1922 uh fighting for Irish unity and
Irish Freedom thank you Mr
Speaker without
[Applause]
objection
it is uh my great great pleasure to
introduce a
friend of the United
States and a country that is our friend
in
Asia Our Guest today has an impressive
resume that covers their career spending
almost 30 years in the foreign
Ministry he first entered into the
foreign Ministry in 1997 and has served
in various capacities including first
Secretary to many embassies including
Israel Russia and mission of EU
Belgium he was Deputy Cil General in
Houston Texas minister of Embassy in
Sweden and Depon secretary to the
president for protocol and now is
serving as a council General to the
Republic of the Korea in Boston his
experience in fostering and
strengthening relationships with
numerous embassies both both here and
abroad have secured the trust friendship
as those he has worked
with now as a friend to New Hampshire
and in the spirit of our relations
between the Republic of Korea and the
United States I'd like to give a warm
welcome to council General Kim J we and
thank him for joining us in New
Hampshire House of Representatives
[Applause]
today
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much very warm welcome
honorable Shaman Adam deer speaker
of the house and respected the
representatives of the general court of
New
Hampshire I am deeply honored to have
the privilege of addressing this the E
chamber today and this is my first time
to visit actually Conor 2 and inside of
that house I arrived around one hours
ago but I'm already got very strong
strong impression about this House's
long history and especially very warm
Hospitality thank you very much allow me
to express my heart Bel appreciation for
the opportunity extend to me as the
council general of the Republic of Korea
to speak before all of
you I'm generally the grateful for the
warm welcome and generous Hospital
Hospitality according to me
today I wish to ref upon the enduring
relationship between Korea and the state
of the New
Hampshire as well as the aspiration and
contribution of the Korean American
community in the state of the New
Hampshire my aim is to
underscore the promising potential of
our mutually benefit icial future across
the variet of spheres including economy
and culture and the
Beyond as we contemplate the century old
tithes between Korea and New Hampshire a
moment of particular significance
emerg the poas peace treaty of 19
05 this pivotal moment not only
underscore the relationship between
Korea and the United States in the early
20th centuries but
also the offer the insight into the
Korea the
trajectory following the acknowledgement
of the postmus as the host City the
peace treaty at the conclusion of the
luo Japanese war in
1905 two Korean individual two Korean
gentlemen one preacher and the other one
it graduate student
ENT the S an audience with them US
president Theodor Rosevelt bearing the
letter of appealing of the desperate
hope of the Korean people for my
country's
Independence they sold the support for
the B the vulnerable Korea from the
United States the United States is the
first The Diplomatic the the friends
allies in our history in international
Ally that time in
1905 Korea was slepping into to the
grasp of Dan Japanese
colonialism despite their meeting with
the Secretary of State then secretary of
state did William teft and also the
president himself there lack of the
familiarity of the international
politics and reg the constraint of the
time they unfortunately could not
participate
in the postas the peace conference and
even they were hinder their conveyance
of Korean wish to the conference
itself I Envision now two Korean
gentlemen standing outside the Vue of
the conference nebor shyat of pus during
that peace treaty the the peace treaty
the proing
maybe they were weeping and they thought
about the Korea's future very the the
desperate future of Korea 43 years later
one of them one of them the greatest
student he became the Korea's the first
president of independent
country while the initial interaction
between Korea and New Hampshire may have
been been marked by these historical
challenges it has evolved into a
relationship characterized by
hope Korean immigration to the New
Hampshire is set to commen in the early
1960s primarily consisting of families
accompaning the US military personnels
stationed at mainly the former peace
airport space in the town of Newington
and Greenland and city of
pmas today we start the Korean
immigration start like this but today a
very vibrant Korean community of
approximately
5,500 Korean American and Korean
Nationals reside here actively
contributing to the community and
enriching the state's
diversity I today I'm very much
privileged to introduce a few the Korean
leaders of that the korean-american
community here we are who are present in
this chamber today the second floor the
first law of few Korean the leaders they
are present today could you stand
up
[Applause]
[Music]
thank
you our
partnership though relatively young is
founded on mutual respect and
cooperation forsted by the strong
alliance between the United States and
Republic of Korea
last year
2023 was a very special year marked the
70th anniversary of our alliance at the
same time
120 years anniversary of Korean
immigration to the United States last
year the special year was celebrated by
the state visit of the president of the
Republic of Korea to Washington DC at
the same time to Massachusetts Boston
and El elevating our relationship to a
global comprehensive strategic Alliance
it means that the Republic of Korea and
United States will increase our
comprehensive the global cooperation
deepen our lowest Regional engagement
and broaden our bilateral ties Guided by
our shared commitment such as as
universal the human right freedom and
Rule of
role Korea and unit Korea and the state
of New Hampshire have explored
opportunity for collaboration across
various the domains including trade and
Advanced
Technologies and the Machine
manufacturing education and also winter
sports and tourism very many various
areas
while our
relationship has yet to reach its full
potential in terms of economic
cooperation trade and human exchanges we
acknowledge the promising Prospect for
cooperation in many fields which I will
elaborate on
shortly
furthermore our
relationship is deeply interwin with the
bellor and sacrifice of New Hampshire's
son and daughters who bravely the vot as
Korean War veterans and as
soldiers on us basis in Korean
Peninsula during the Korean war from
1950 to
1953 more than 10,000 soldiers from the
New Hampshire fought together with
Korean
soldiers among them
137 son from the New Hampshire they made
it ultimate
sacrifice their contribution their
sacrifice their devotion rais the
foundation for Curious Lefty development
into a vibrant democracy and economic
Powerhouse we the Korean Korean
community and all every Korean
commemorate their service their devotion
and their sacrifice through
memorials and
commemorations underscoring their
pivotal role in Korea's
transformation every year around the
date of July
27 the date of the Armistice signing of
the Armistice of the Korean War at the
bosan the state Veteran Cemetery Korean
American the association in New
Hampshire together with veterans
association whole of the commemoration
ceremony Korean War veterans and their
families
last year I had the honor to
attend that ceremony and had touching
moment meeting Korean War and
Veterans the ceremony was held for
expressing the Koreans the Gratitude to
their services of veterans but one
veterans that gra my hands and said to
me
thank you very much for making Korea
such a wonderful
country Korea made my effort and my
Cardis
sacrifice utmost
meaningful I was speechless and could
only express just a thank you to
him this year the commemoration ceremony
will be held at the same B menu on July
28th and I'm looking forward to meeting
that veteran again this time I will
prefer to properly convey my sincere
thanks thanks on behalf of all Korean
people now I would like to look ahead to
our future relations I
inion even greater the potential and
opportunity through the activities and
initiatives of both the Korean community
and business in New Hampshire firstly
the Korean American community of New
Hampshire actively engage in Social
contribution and forer a strong
scene strong sense of citizenship as
evidenced by the cultural exchanges
event and community activities
last February I was invited to 2024 this
year's Luna New Years Festival hosted by
the Korean Community here it was held at
very beautiful Church in the town of
Greenland and it was a wonderful and
very beautiful the Gathering bringing
together the member of the Korean the
community but also neighbors together
there I witnessed
the future of the Korean
Community Korea came to the New
Hampshire as a small number of the
migrant they successfully settled down
and now integral members of the local
community driven by a desire to make
contribution to their communities and FU
by a fashion for the New Hampshire I
believe the Korean American community of
New Hampshire will continue to make
contribution to their community and
defen diversity as a bridge to promoting
Mutual understanding among citizens
here Korean business are also eager to
explore economic cooperation with New
Hampshire attracted by very strong High
tax ecosystem here and also is strategic
the location and also very attractive
the incentive too while the investment
in New Hampshire have yet to materialize
we believe there is a significant potent
potential for the collaboration the city
of the portas and also the Manchester
and also city of conco too be a possible
Banu good Banu for the Korean business
and Company to explore new investment
and partners in this regard I kindly
urge the your attention and also the
support for the mutual the cooperation
between Korea and New Hampshire I would
like draw your attention one issue it is
regarding to the Korean student who
studying in University of and the
college in New Hampshire who I believe
could significantly contribute
contribute to the economic and social
the cooperation between Korea and the
New
Hampshire New Hampshire is Renown is
excellence in fields such as the health
carees education and
tourism currently there are
approximately 200 Korean national the
student enrolled in you Hampshire the
high educational
institution the number is not big now
but I can say the number is increasing
recently so after the pandemic the
number of the Korean exchange student
come to the New England area so the
number of student looking for the
opportunity in New Hampshire is
increasing
in total number in New England area the
Korean students is around
3,500 all the United States
44,000 the Korean student the number
itself is number third the Chinese and
next India and the South Korea Republic
Korea the the number of the student is
number is third places in student in
exchange program
but if you think about the size of the
population of those three countries
China India is more than billion people
live there in Korea now we have around
50 million yes huge number small country
but if you consider the number size of
the population how many Korean student
try to come to the United States for
studying and for their the future the
job and professional
matter is despite the Korea being a
close Ally and the major investor in
critical supply chain for the United
States Korean student are facing some
status problem Bea the programs upon
graduation some of them forcing to leave
the United States the Korean government
is striving to increase the Visa
quarters for the Korean through the
bipartisan bill called the partner with
Korea act which aim to enable highly
skilled Korean professional to
contribute to the United States taking
this opportunity I kindly request the
support of New Hampshire State the
registrator present here to endorse our
Korean government effort and urge member
of the US Congress both in the House and
Senate to recognize the significance of
the bill and facilitate is passage
before this meeting I have a shown
meeting with speaker and other staff of
the State House I heard that's very the
interesting suggestion that so they
really they try to attract some Korean
business to come to the New Hampshire
some manufacturing factories or R&D or
any kind of the cooperation I think if
we can find find our good solution to
this kind of status problem of the
Korean
student it would be very big helpful for
the Korean company to find opportunity
in New Hampshire
too addition to economic cooperation I
have to also mention that cultural and
then tourism cooperation between Korea
and New Hampshire will continue to
expand I think the representatives so
you might heard about the Halu Korean
wave K-pop K drama and the parasite and
many
dramas so the very story of the
remarkable the resilience and innovation
of the Korean culture is gaining now the
global the prominence
prominence as you know the cult culture
serves as a potent instrument for
understanding and building
friendship Halu offer very nice
opportunity good opportunity for the
Korean Community here too to celebrate
their own the Heritage especially for
the Young Generation but also I believe
the Korean culture can play very
important more important roles making
more friend making the different our
understanding together my office and
Korean government we will try hard to
Showcase and also share this Korean
culture with the community
here distinguished speaker of the house
and all the respected
Representatives based on the history
ties between Korea and New Hampshire and
with an active and very healthy Korean
American
communities and considering the
promising potential of mutual
cooperation and most of all with
heartfelt gratitude to the service and
sacrifice of the Son and Daughters of
New Hampshire to the peace and
prosperity and stability of the Korean
Peninsula both the Korean Community here
and also Korean consulate office and
myself and my colleagues we are
committed to promoting New Hampshire in
Korea and fostering mutually beneficial
cooperation across variety sectors let
us continue working together to
strengthening the bonds between Korea
and New Hampshire for the betterment of
both our communities let us strive to
further fortify our ship and friendship
for the future thank you for
[Applause]
[Music]
listening
for what reason does the member rise
thank you Mr Speaker I moved that the
remark from the council General be
printed in the permanent journal without
objection the house will now attended a
consent
calendar Mr Speaker from the committee
on children and family law Senate Bill
359 removed by Representatives yella
Hull santonastaso Tony leus Tom Manion
Alicia leus Gard cordelli dry and petno
from the committee on children and
family law Senate Bill 498 removed by
Representatives Lon Granger MCU Tom
Manion Tony leus mcarter pno papuchi
Mueller Alicia leus and
love are there any other bills to be
removed representative Osborne moves a
consent calendar with the relevant
amendments as printed in today's house
record be adopted you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
post nay the eyes have it consent
calendar is adopted
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following en titled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 261
relative to rights of tenants in cases
of domestic violence representative lyes
that we
recogniz representative Lyn moves we
Concur and is recognized to speak to the
motion thank you uh colleagues I I move
to concur
uh on this bill you may recall we uh
when the house passed this bill um it
contained two Provisions one was a
provision to allow um a person who was a
a victim of domestic violence to
basically um have that as a basis to
terminate a lease and the second was to
allow a person who was a victim of uh
who was who had uh uh been a victim of
an accident or illness to uh to uh
terminate the lease the Senate removed
the second part which really had nothing
to do with the main part of the bill
that dealt with domestic violence it
also made some changes uh to extend the
period during which the domestic
violence might have occurred I believe
our bill said 60 days the Senate
increased that to 150 days and it also
increased uh expanded the types of
notice that could be given uh by a
person who who uh was a vict of domestic
violence importantly this is a an
important change that the Senate made it
creates a new grounds for a landlord to
evict a tenant who causes domestic
violence um which which made made a lot
of sense and the last thing is it is
already part of New Hampshire law that a
um a person who is a victim of domestic
violence uh may not be evicted for that
purpose alone this uh the Senate version
expands what uh what types of proof can
be offered um to uh by S by such a
person uh the Judiciary Committee
considered all of the changes thought it
was appropriate to concur so I recommend
that the house
concur the question is on a motion to
concur on House Bill
261 are you ready for the question
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay guys have it the motion
passes chair recognized representative
wer thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to
remove House Bill 1560 from the table
I'd like to speak to my motion can't
speak I request a division vote to
remove House Bill 156 from the table it
is important in today's dealings and
finance thank you please support
it this is a division vote the the
motion is to remove 1560 from the table
this is a division vote members take
your
seats
e
members take your seats this is a
division
vote this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative walner for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this body voted
to lay this bill on the table and if I
know that's the place it should stay
would I now
vote no thank
you do you recognize wer for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the whole calendar before us is
reliant on taking 1560 off the table and
passing it with a 2/3 vote the 34 bills
if I know that the 34 bills before us on
from the finance committee that almost
half of them passed
unanimously because they were widely
supported in this house many of them
have General
funds to fund them if we do not remove
1560 from the table and if we do not
pass it by 2/3 how are we going to take
care of those important things that need
General funds that you will see in this
calendar please vote Yes to take this
off the table push the green button I
thank
you motion before us is to remove House
Bill 1560 from the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose you
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds St make sure your stations are
on
e
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house attend to stay to the
vote 177 voting a 2011 voting a the
motion
fails chair chair recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker Senate Bill 523 has been sent
over from the other body uh and at this
point because the subject matter was
indefinitely postponed the only way that
that can be introduced is with a vote um
of 2/3 to consider introduction so the
motion uh at this time would be to
consider um whether to
introduce motion before us is to
consider introduction of Senate Bill 553
FN this will be a division vote this
will be a division vote members take
your
seats
youve done this
the motion is to
consider allowing Senate Bill
223 FN to be introduced this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
e
represent
Elber well lacking twoth thirds you can
all see the motion
failed we will now attend to the regular
calendar
committee on Finance St Jose F House
Bill 318 FNA act relative to bail
Commissioners and making Appropriations
to the judicial branch consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation Bill ought to
pass with Amendment Senor Peter leechman
for the committee the amendment is
144h printed in house record 14 pages 24
through 31 the question and the motion
is on the amendment Amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say
iose nay the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I iose nay the eyes have
it and the committee amendment is
adopted on that last
represent on the last vote
representative scitech declared a
conflict and did not
participate majority of the committee on
finance to which was referred House Bill
10005 FN act relative to judicial
training considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate weent of Dan Maguire for the
committee
minority of the committee on finance to
which was referred House Bill 10 10005
FN having considered the same being
unable to agree with the majority report
the recommendation Bill ought to pass
representative Jr H for the minority of
the committee for what reason does it
member rise thank you Mr Speaker I move
to table
hb15 it is a proper motion the motion
before us is a table House Bill
10005 are you you ready for the
question are you ready for the
question a division has been called
members take your
seats
e
the motion before us is to table house
bill 10005 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative Sweeny for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know the contents of
hb15 were just included in the
bipartisan bail reform package we just
voted for and Mr Speaker if I further
know that tabling the contents of
hb15 might be able to protect it from
any nonsense the other side of the wall
might bring to it would I now vote green
to table hb15 thank you J recognize
represent H for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the contents in
hb15 are in House Bill 318 but the issue
is so important it should stand on its
own if I know that training Those Who
oversee family court issues is of utmost
importance to our citizen what I vote
against the table motion so we could
pass the Bill separately to send to the
body behind us thank
you the motion before us is the table
house bill5 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if be opposed or press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote 348 voting a 33 voting a house bill
10005 is light on the
table
majority committee on finance to which
was referred House Bill
1178 FN act relative to an employes
unused earned time considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
the bill be referred for interim study
sen of Jr H for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Chuck
grassy from the minority of the
committee CH recognizes representative
grassy thank you Mr
Speaker House
Bill
1178 uh is a bill that we heard before
the committee and we've had it before
the committee many times it's been
before this floor we've passed it out of
this floor many times before when it
came came to the finance committee it
came basically with no cost Bill didn't
cost us a
thing what I'm hoping today is that
we'll be able to overturn this interim
study report and recommendation and that
we can move on to further further
question to pass
this the amendment that we have proposed
addresses concerns that UNH had and
limits the acred time to 30
days the bill more important L only
affects businesses that have 15 or more
employees and it only affects those
situations where a business closed is
sold or people are laid
off now this is important particularly
the last one I have a true story I can
tell you I will tell you of two
employees that worked for a
business one employee started applied
applied for job and was hired for that
business the the handbook said that
during your first year of employment
whenever you are hired you get three
days of free time or personal time or
sick time that you can use this person
started in
February your acred vacation time starts
in January and it AC CRS on January 1st
that's when you get your vacation time
and after working one year you get one
week acre on January 1st after that
first year that you've worked after 3
years you get two weeks after 5 years
you get three weeks and after 10 years
you get four weeks of
vacation second person started working
for that same company he started in
August his time he'd only work there for
three years the first employee worked
there for 10 years so he had four weeks
of employment the second gentleman
starts company he worked there for three
years when covid
hit Co hit in
March Human Resources came in that
morning and said to all the employees
business will be closing at midnight
tonight your insurance your personal
health insurance will end at midnight
tonight we'll call you back when we see
if how
things how things play out with this
covid
issue the second employee who had been
there for three
years used his vacation time his two
weeks which he had vacation time used
them in
February the second person who' been
there for 10 years was planning on
taking two weeks in the summer one week
at Thanksgiving and one week at
Christmas which he had usually done
throughout the year prior to getting
four weeks of vacation he was going to
take one year in this week in the summer
one year at Thanksgiving one week at
Christmas he got
nothing not a
thing you may hear that this
bill overrides human Union contracts it
doesn't you may say that this is going
to affect businesses inappropriately it
doesn't it affects those people who have
been laid off where they promised that
they were going to get vacation time and
then did not get their vacation time or
if a business is sold or a business
closes They will receive the time that
was promised to them in the
handbook most handbooks say you only
will get your vacation time if you leave
employment you give you two weeks notice
well when you're laid off or the
business closes you can't give two weeks
notice
and so businesses have been using that
not to pay AC crude
time time that you have worked for and
you have
earned many people on high-tech say well
we have Flex time they can take as much
time as they want well statistics have
shown that that doesn't always work out
and they don't usually get as much time
but this bill is not something that is
for those people this is something that
is for the people who work hard work
hourly show up every morning go home
every evening or show up every evening
and go home every
morning it's for those people hourly
employees we're capping this at 30
days that recruit time so business would
not be responsible for any more than
that but it's a fair thing to do when
you came here you came here to represent
your
constituents those people who go to work
in the morning those people who carry
the lunch pail this is a bill for them I
would encourage you to vote no on this
interim study so that we can bring an
amendment and an ought to pass motion on
this Bill thank
you Jer recogize representative
infantine thank you Mr Speaker the
motion on the
floor is for inter room
study I've learned a lot of things in my
tenure here in the legislature if you
spare me a minute or two I'm going to
tell you a couple things I've
learned I was younger years ago and
representative nelli was the speaker of
the house and a bill came in front of
Labor and it wasn't quite
ready it got passed through the house
and the
Senate the governor signed the
bill the Hue and cry because of the bill
that came from business owners in New
Hampshire both Democrat Republican and
independent was so
Furious that the first order of
business the second year of the term on
organization day was to repeal that bill
the bill wasn't
ready I won't pass another bill
again that's not
ready I don't think this is
ready I'm not going to Discount and the
second thing I've learned is not to pass
something in the house when I know in
here that it's not going to go any
further in the other
body I don't
discount
what the previous speaker
stated the law as it is now needs to be
amended needs to be
tweaked the bill has three parts to it
two of which I agree to agree with and
would support and have told the sponsor
I will support at
nauseum the third one is
not it's not
ready and I don't want to go back to
what happened the last time
that I didn't speak up hard enough that
we have to repeal a bill on organization
day the next day I would
appreciate if you would go with a motion
on the floor of referendum study thank
you Mr Speaker and I would like a roll
call Representative intine has requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
e
motion before us is interim study on
House Bill
1178 a roll call has been
requested chair recogniz representative
Michael Cahill for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I
know that in the interest of fairness to
employees and employers who re who value
their employees and want to retain them
and and have them have long careers
where they contribute I think we should
that we should pass uh that we should
defeat the interim study and pass the
bill Mr Speaker if I know that we don't
do one siiz fits all in this in this
body and that the fact that a an
employer may tell the employee that you
have two weeks vacation per year and
because of my one-size fits-all blanket
policy that if uh if I lay you off and
it's not your choice I lay you off that
you don't get the vacation pay I think
that's I think we should shouldn't allow
that in the state of New Hampshire and
then I would say that we should vote
down the interim study and and press the
red button then Mr Speaker what I now
conclude and ask you to again press that
red button so we may go forward and and
impress the other body with our
steadfastness and uh pass this Bill
thank you here recognize representative
infantine for parliamentary inquiry
representative in time weighs off the
motion before us is interim study on 11
House Bill 1178
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote 188 voting a 193 voting a the
motion
fails representative Grassi moves aop
pass and
offers Amendment 1256 H printed in house
record 14 page 31 are you ready for the
question on the
amendment all those in favor say I
I oppose
nay Vision has re been requested for
clarification only people in the chamber
can
vote
your voting stations should be open the
motion is a clarification vote on the
amendment if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
representive
Hill
represent
pamon represent
re
represent all members present have an
opportunity to vote also tend to stay
the vote
197 voting a 185 voting a amendment is
adopted a motion before us now is ought
to pass as
amended representative Granger has asked
for a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
PR
the motion before us is a to pass as
amended onh House Bill 1178 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you press the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
e
[Music]
while members present opportunity to
vote also attend to state of the
vote 198 voting nay 183 voting nay the
motion of autop pass is amended is
adopted majority of the committee on
finance to which was referred house 11
199 FNA an act relative to Services of
the office of the child advocate for
youth experience in homelessness and
making appropri appropriation therefore
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate Senate
Sweeney for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation to Bill ought to pass
representative Chuck grassy from the
minority of the
committee chair recognizes
representative
grassy thank you Mr
Speaker let's take a look at the
financial aspects of 1199 first this was
sent to finance after it came out of a
policy committee here in the house the
bill ask for an appropriation of
$150,000 to be paid for by the American
from the American Rescue plan it doesn't
actually ask for any money out of the
budget and it also asks that we look at
other federal funds that may be
available for child
homelessness in future years this
program would be rolled into the
budget this asked for one position and
the financial audit report that we got
from from the legislative budget office
said in the first year they would ask
for $882,000
actually when we look at
$199 we have to consider that youth
homelessness in New
Hampshire is a critical issue
one in 10 children ages 18 to 24 are in
homelessness one in 30 from 13 to 70 are
housing
insecure recent data shows that New
Hampshire has one of the top three
largest increases in youth homelessness
in the state in the
nation HB 1199 relative to Services of
the office of child advocate of Youth
Services experience home homelessness
asked for one
coordinator right now there are two
people in that department and what they
do is they work with people that are in
the
system if a student is or a child is in
DCF the juvenile justice system or
foster care they get services from The
Advocate and that covers a lot of kids
in our
state statutorily requ this department
is required to work with the
children but there is a small group of
children that are outside of that Cate
these categories that are not picked up
and cannot be picked up
statutorily they cannot work with these
children many of the children that are
that are found homeless in
schools when they're reported they may
be reported to dcyf only 50% of those
kids are actually picked up the rest of
them are said no you know go back and
work with your family we we see we see
many of these children who are
lgbtq many families full families that
are homeless or people that children
that are not who are out of their homes
for another
reason they are being missed with the
services that may be available to
them the majority report talks about
well this increases the age to 25 as
well so we're going to pick up a lot of
people that that are older and that
they're adults well HUD actually
redefined what a youth is and it
basically you look at 13 to 25 Now by
Hud so if you're looking at federal
funds you've got to expand that age
group but we're not really looking at
that many people in that
category last year the office
of child advocate had nine sex
trafficking
cases in the state of New Hampshire nine
and I know that's an important thing for
a lot of people here because I've heard
a lot of people talk about sex
trafficking but I've got something
different sex trafficking you know you
take a look at that and that's when a
child is forced into
sex A N A 2022 study here in New
Hampshire showed that there were 1500
homeless school
children 40% of them
participate now remember these two words
I'm they participate in survival
sex that's not a choice that they make
readily that's not something they've
been forced into that's something
they're looking for a place to lay their
head at night or to get a meal 40% of
those 1500 students who were surveyed
said they participate in survival sex
out of 500 proximately 500 college
students who are homeless or housing in
Shakur they may sleep on a couch they
may sleep in a car they may sleep in a
tent 26% of them now these are the older
ones who may be able to fend for some
themselves a little bit bit better 26%
of them experienced survival
sex if we're taking a look at survival
sex and we're saying it's not important
that we do something about it by
bringing another advocate in the
department who can handle and work with
these cases confine these cases and
coordinate
Services what are we doing and why are
we
here thank you Mr Speaker I'll call for
a roll
call chair recognize representative
Sweeny
thank you thank you Mr Speaker I do want
to thank the gentleman from Rochester
for his speech he did lay out the
specifics and the facts on this bill uh
which I do just want to highlight this
bill does expand the role of the office
of the child advocate which is currently
focused on those kids in the system uh
to individuals it this bill would expand
their scope to individuals up to the age
of 25 that are experiencing homelessness
and while the committee certainly felt
that and and knows that homelessness is
a problem that we have to deal with in
our municipalities and throughout the
state of New Hampshire this bill spends
money not for one more single bed uh to
be opened up in any town or city in the
State uh this bill is using onetime
federal dollars from the American Rescue
plan act that the state has to spend by
the end of this year and using that to
hire a new state employee expanding the
scope of the current Office of the child
advocate and in the future we'd have to
take that employee and pay them with
taxpayer dollars it's not the way we do
things here in New Hampshire we use
onetime money for one-time expenses uh
this money could be better used on more
shelters on beds to expand the the need
that we have there not on an additional
state employee that is simply going to
be a coordinator for the alleged
resources that are out there that aren't
being connected uh to those in need
right now um I'm not going to belabor
the point it is obviously an emotional
and charged uh topic and and we all have
sympathy for the issue uh but expanding
the scope of the office of child
advocate to individuals up to the age of
25 uh using one-time funds for a for
forever employee that the state would
then be on the hook for is just not a
sensible policy in my opinion uh and why
the finance committee urges you to agree
with the majority committee report of
inexpedient to legislate thank you very
much representative grassy has request a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
e
motion before us is any exped majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislator and House Bill 1199 this is a
roll call vote chair recognizes
representative long for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that very very little understanding of
framework are focused on homeless youth
under the age of 18 and above and if I
know that all the New Hampshire data
shows an increase in this
demographic and if I know tens of
millions of tax dollars are appropriated
in servicing adult homelessness and
believe we could reduce that amount by
investing at the earliest age and
finally if I if I believe 150,000 in Opa
funding of this position in the office
of advocacy gives us the opportunity to
begin to complete the circle and deliver
in productive citizens than when I press
the red button thank you Mr Speaker
chair recognize C warer for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that using temporary funding
to hire a new employee is not sound
financial planning we already have a
person in the office of child advocate
who was taken on some of this Challenge
and if I further know that we also have
a special committee working on
housing if I know that this may come
down to spending money of
150,000 that would do very little to
solve the problem that has been
discussed would I now push the green
button and find some other way to fix
this problem thank
you motion before us the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legisl on House Bill 1199 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
or press the red button voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent Wendy
Thomas represent Wendy
Thomas all members president have an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 190 voting a 191 voting nay the
motion
fails grasses to pass representative
grassy moves ought to
pass a division has been requested
members take your
seats of run requested a roll call is
that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote
the motion before us is to pass on House
Bill 1199 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're oppos you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds
represent
Sween represent
pamon
all members present had an opportunity
to vote hous will attend to stay to the
vote 191 voting a 192 voting a and and I
did vote for what reason do member rise
Mr Speaker I would move to lay House
Bill 1199 on the
table motion before us is the L House
table a division has been
requested everybody should still be in
their
seats okay uh roll call has been
request said roll
call
the motion before us is the table House
Bill
1199 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative papovich
Mueller for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that when
uh the original vote happened I uh
inadvertently voted the wrong way on the
uh original itl motion would I uh oppose
the motion to table so we can reconsider
the original vote thank
you the motion before us is the table
House Bill 1199 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds
represent PE
represent Juliet
Smith all members present had an
opportunity to vote also attend to stay
to
vote 189 voting a 193 voting a the
motion
fails
for what reason does a member rise thank
you Mr Speaker I move to indefinitely
postpone HB
1199 motion before us is to indefinitely
postpone House Bill
1199 a division has been
requested represent Sweeney asked for a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
is sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
everybody was in the chamber Mr Speaker
nobody was out of
theber
okay the motion before us now is
indefinitely postpone House Bill 1199
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
where's there
[Music]
Brian all members president had an
opportunity to vote also tend to stay to
the
vote 192 voting a 190 voting aay
definite postponement
passes committee on finance to referred
House Bill 1202 FN an act relative to
issuance of permits for the alteration
of driveways exiting into public ways
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment a
recommendation to Bill AO pass with
Amendment s of Tracy Emich for the
committee the amendment is 0971 H
printed in house record 14 pages 31
through 32 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I oppose nay the eyes have
it the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I suppose nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted for what reason is to
memorize I would like to place the
remarks on 1199 in the permanent Journal
wait it's awful awful noisy in
here you please repeat your motion I
would like for the remarks on HB 1199 to
be placed in the permanent Journal
without
objection
majority of committee on finance to
which was referred House Bill 1212 FN
local an act relative to eligibility for
free School meals considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate pres of Daniel papovich
Mueller for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass represented Mary Heath for the
minority of the committee for what
reason is member rise thank you Mr
Speaker I move to table
hb212 swiy moves a table House Bill
roll representative Luna requests a roll
call that is sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call
vote
okay the motion before us is to table
House Bill one 12 two this is going to
be a roll call vote chair
recognize chair recognizes
representative for a
lad for a uh parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know this raises the eligibility
threshold for the free and reduced
program from
185% to 350% or if amended
250% at taxpayer
expense and if I also know that we
received in committee competing fiscal
data reports that ranged anywhere from
50 to100 million to support this program
would I then press the green button
chair recognize representative hall for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know the intent of House
Bill 1212 is simple to support families
who are vulnerable by providing greater
access to school meals for
children and if I know the school meals
play a critical role in a student's
attendance Behavior well-being and
academic success and if I I know that
defeating the table motion would give us
the opportunity to discuss the
merits uh of House Bill 1212 and the
financial impact of lowering the
eligibility incap income cap from 350
down to a modest
250% in an amendment that we would like
to present then would I now press the no
button so that we can hear debate on
House Bill 1212 thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us it's a table House Bill
1212 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
be
all members present have opportunity to
vote house will attend to state to the
vote 192 voted yay 191 voting
nay 1212 is laid on the table and the
speaker did
vote
committee on finance to which was
referred House Bill 1282 FN an act
relative to duration of child report
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment s of Jess Edwards
for the committee the amendment is 11868
printed in house record 14 page 32 are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I those
oppose nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay the
eyes have it and the committee report is
adoped
chair recognized representative Osborne
for an
announcement thank you uh legislators
and staff are welcome to go down to the
cafeteria for the annual Walmart lunch
and health
screening
yeah the house will be in recess until
1:30
e
house Bill 1288 FN act relative to
establishing certain due process rights
for students student organizations and
faculty members facing disciplinary
actions by state institutions of higher
in learning consider the same report the
same with a recommendation the bill
ought to
pass sen of Tracy amrich for the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
and being unable to agree with the
majority resolved Report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate sen of Mary
Harkin Phillips for the minority of the
committee the chair recognized
representative hen
Phillips for what reason does a member
rise to make a motion Mr Speaker State
your motion I'd like to uh move to table
House Bill
1288 table House Bill
1288 the mo the motion the motion is is
to table House Bill 1288 representative
Sweeney has requested a roll call is
that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your
seats
e
house house will be in
order the motion before us is to table
house bill 1288 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes hark PHS to uh for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that HB 1288 is a fiscally irresponsible
unfunded mandate charged to New
Hampshire's higher educational system if
I also know that a that New Hampshire
has already an existing higher
educational disciplinary process that's
appropriate and fair and if I also know
that New Hampshire taxpayers have
already paid for the New Hampshire court
system that guarantees and to protect
our due process rights then would I now
press the green button and support the
motion to place HB 1288 on the table
thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognized representative
Lynn for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this that this body
considered this bill roughly two or
three weeks ago and that no and and
supported it and that nothing
substantial has changed in the last two
or three weeks including after the
finance committee's review of the bill
then would I press the red button uh to
to uh defeat the tabling motion so that
we may proceed to the merits thank you
Mr Speaker and I would ask for a roll
call
vote the motion before us is uh tbling
House Bill
1288 roll call is this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds damn it I did it
again I did
it
[Music]
house will be in
order hang on I'm checking please
represent
stavis represent you need to sit
please
represent
Barry all members pres have the
opportunity to vote vote you already
know what the results are 180 voting y
186 voting a the motion to table fails
we're back to the original motion of aut
to pass chair recognizer representative
Hain
Phillips thank you Mr
Speaker I rise today in opposition to
the octopath motion for HB 1288 sponsors
of the bill seek to correct a perceived
unfairness within the higher education
disciplinary process so that a more
robust due process right system is
assured when students faculty or
organizations face suspension expulsion
or termination the sponsors say more due
process equals more fairness and more
fairness that's just a good thing but
guys this bill is not that simple and it
has serious consequences Mr Speaker the
math just doesn't add up so let's crunch
the numbers zero zero evidence was
presented of any student faculty member
or organization within New Hampshire's
higher ed system that was denied their
due process right when undergoing a
suspension or a greater discipline why
because those currently subject to
potential discipline are already given
notice of the charges for which they are
accused a meaningful opportunity to
respond and an impartial decision maker
these are all Essential Elements to Du
process here's another number zero zero
students faculty members or
organizations who are denied access to
the existing New Hampshire court system
to seek remedies for these supposed due
VI due process
violations how about one one giant
conflict of state federal and contract
law under this law state law would be
required to put a pause on all higher
educational disciplinary processes while
criminal cases are working through the
New Hampshire court system which we all
know takes some time
but under federal law with millions of
in Title 9 funding tied to it that
Federal Law requires immediate
protective order enforcement for cases
involving sexual harassment sexual
violence and racial
discrimination further this bill would
put into state law a direct conflict
with collective bargaining agreements in
the higher educational Community for
faculties because uh because faculties
have shared governance agreements and
independent AR arbitration clauses built
in to their
contracts here's another one zero zero
attention paid to the unintended
consequences of this bill with all the
focus on the rights of the accused there
was no concern about the absence of
federal Rules of Evidence protecting VI
victim's rights who are um subject to
sexual
violence zero zero Appropriations are
tied to this bill although it's clear
there would be a significant increase in
New Hampshire's higher Educational
Systems administrative burden that's
right the university system anticipates
a$1 to2 million increase and the
community college system anticipates
over
$370,000 increases of expenses per year
to comply with this bill so make no
mistake hb1 1288 is an unfunded a hefty
unfunded Mandate of state
law one more number zero zero estimates
of the true cost the true unknown but
very significant legal cost
to defend New Hampshire's Educational
Systems under this bill taxpayers will
ultimately pay the price in the probably
Millions to litigate this bill and
believe me litigation will be coming Mr
Speaker those numbers don't make sense
but here are two numbers that do make
sense one one existing New Hampshire
court system that is already established
and paid for by New Hampshire
taxpayers that guarantees our due
process rights this
bill and the many other fundamental
freedoms that are guaranteed under our
state constitution and our Federal
Constitution one New Hampshire judicial
system that has worked efficiently and
effectively for hundreds of years and
under which the current higher education
systems disciplinary process
honors and one one hb1 1288 is one heck
of an example of a fine jobs bill this
bill if
enacted should forever be known as the
make New Hampshire higher ed acquire
great attorneys act because as far as I
can tell the major beneficiary of the
secondary quasi judicial process within
the state H Ed will be the members of
the New Hampshire Bar Association and
behalf of all the members i' like to
thank the sponsors for establishing the
title wave of impending new jobs for
attorneys to litigate the truly novel
cases of New Hampshire state law
conflicting with federal law and
breaches of contract all parties will be
more likely to lawyer up and come on who
doesn't like more
lawyers so 1 plus 1 equals 2 that maap
that maap definitely checks out Mr
Speaker and that's two solid reasons for
you to oppose the OTP motion finally hb1
1288 is a fiscally irresponsible bill
when we already have an existing higher
educational disciplin disciplinary
process that's appropriate and fair and
when taxpayers have already paid for the
New Hampshire court system that
guarantees our due process rights
when that process fails for these
reasons Mr Speaker I urge you to vote no
on the OTP motion so that another more
fiscally prudent motion may be made
thank you Mr Speaker chair recognize
representative
Lynn thank you m thank you Mr Speaker I
Rise as I did two weeks ago or maybe
three weeks ago in support of the ought
to pass motion on this bill uh as was
just noted this bill establishes certain
due process rights for faculty students
or student organizations that are facing
disciplinary significant disciplinary
action involving suspensions
Etc one of the things we didn't hear in
from the prior speaker is which of the
rights that I'll read to you now are
somehow unfair the right to notice of
the charges to advanc disclosure of
witnesses and evidence to the
presumption of innocence and a
requirement that that the the uh the AL
the the uh complainant Prov the case by
a preponderance of the evidence the
privilege against
self-incrimination the right to confront
and cross examine Witnesses the right to
an impartial hearings officer and I
could go on which of those is is a right
that's unfair I submit to you that none
of them are the argument here by the by
the university system is on the one hand
they say oh our system is just fine
there's no problem don't worry about it
well if that's true then there is no
problem with this bill either because
this bill says if you have an equivalent
system then you can continue to use your
system and while we did hear complaints
during this whole process from the
University system one of the things that
was very interesting if this was going
to upset all these established
procedures that unions and and and uh
the the school schools had agreed to you
might think that some time during the
hearing process we would have heard some
people from the union saying oh don't do
this this will be terrible if you do it
we heard Zero from the unions because
they they this is not going to be some
huge problem the last point that I'll
make is this the suggestion that there
somehow is a conflict between this and
federal law and that we're going to get
sued I'll tell you stop and think about
this this would be the federal
government's argument for trying to
defund New Hampshire because we had this
law well we should defund New Hampshire
because they have a system in place to
to resolve disciplinary problems that's
too Fair it gives too much fairness to
the parties can you imagine I mean I as
you know as a lawyer I would I would pay
to sit in the back of the courtroom and
listen to that argument before a judge
defund New Hampshire because they have a
process that's too fair I submit to you
it's a it it would go absolutely nowhere
for the reason stated I urge you to vote
press the green button and vote all to
pass on this uh motion thank you and Mr
Speaker I ask for a division vote
representative Granger was asked for a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
e
motion before is ought to pass on House
Bill 1288 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Kate Murray
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
current system is efficient expeditious
and cost effective and if I know that
our Prime sponsor has joined many others
in commending our University system for
the highly professional manner in which
it deals with these complaints lengths
and if I know that this bill only adds
another layer of bureaucracy and red
tape to A system that is already
addressing the concerns expressed in
this bill and if I know that this bill
has an unknown fiscal component that
could be very expensive and at the same
time this bill could put into Jeopardy
critical Federal funding when I now
press the red button to defeat this
motion and allow a successful program to
function successfully without additional
and unnecessary burdens thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
emmer for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know this bill is setting
forth a standard for all of our
institutions of higher education I can't
find a lot wrong with that and if I also
know that according to testimony from
the University system last year there
were 20,000 incidents of those 80 went
to a hearing I don't think that's an
overburdensome task for 80 hearings
please press the green
button the motion before us is the
majority committee report of Auto auto
pass on House Bill 1288 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposer
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
time
[Music]
while members present at an opportunity
to vote H will attend to say the
vote 196 voting a 184 voting a Comm
report is
adopted for what reason does a member
rise to make a Motion state it to print
the remarks of the last debate in the
permanent
journal without
objection committee on finance to which
was referred House Bill 1304 FN local
act relative to vessel registration and
boat fee decals consider the same report
the same with the following Amendment
the recommendation Bill L to pass with
Amendment sen of Daniel Papa vich
Mueller for the committee the amendment
is 0933 AG printed in house record 14
page 32 are you ready for the question
on the amendment all those in favor say
I I oppose nay the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted motion before us
now is ought to pass with Amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the committee report is
adopted committee on finance to which
was referred House Bill 1307 FN an act
providing a supplemental appropriation
for the members of the retirement system
receiving an accidental disability
retirement allowance consider the same
report the same the recommendation the
bill ought to pass s of Dan Maguire for
the committee are you ready for the
question all those in
favor
representative Maguire ask for a
division this will be a division vote me
take seat members take your
seats
a
motion before us is aut to pass on House
Bill 1307 f and this is a division vote
chair recogniz representative M Dan
Maguire for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker I just wanted to
apologize my um blurb in the calendar is
slightly incorrect um I I had the amount
40,000 I'm
sorry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that my blurb in the calendar is
slightly Incorrect and if I know that
the correct amount is $50,000 not
$40,000 and if I apologize to you Mr
Speaker and to the house for that error
would I now press the green button thank
you the motion before us is ought to
pass on houseb 1307 FN this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposer
press a red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent stop
all members present opportunity to vote
also tend say the
vote 330 363 voting yay 17 voting aay
committee report is
adopted committee on finance to which
was referred House Bill 1339 FN an act
relative to background checks during
motions to return firearms and
ammunition consider the same report the
same with a recommendation the bill
ought to pass pres of Joseph Petri for
the committee are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the committee report is
adopted committee on finance to which
was ferred House Bill 1355 FN act
relative to the New Hampshire National
guide Recruitment and reenlistment
incentive program having considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation the bill a to pass sen
Joe Sweeney for the committee are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the committee report is
adopted majority of the committee on
finance to which was referred House Bill
1363 FN act relative to allowing members
of the general court to participate in
the Department of Health and Human
Services employee assistance program
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate sen of Jess
Edwards for the minority of the majority
of the committee minority of the
committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following Amendment the
recommendation Bill ought to pass with
Amendment sen Laura Toki for the
minority of the committee for what
reason it member rise thank you Mr
Speaker I move to table HB
1363 representative move has moved to
table House Bill 1363 a division has
been called members take your
seats
e
the motion before us is a table House
Bill 1363 this is a division vote chair
recognizes repres sentive Sweeney for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill would enroll
state legislators in an employee State
system uh for benefits and if I further
know that we are not employees of the
state we are legislators of the state
would I now press the green button to
put this bill on the table chair
recognized representative tki for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill encourages the well-being
and productivity of legislators and
would help all of us serve our
constituents better and if I know the
minority has an amendment that addresses
the concerns that majority had in the
committee and we can only see that if we
overturn this motion and if I know that
these same constituents that we will be
able to serve better sent us here to
debate issues like this and would I vote
no on the tabling motion to hear the
debate thank you Mr Speaker the motion
before us is the table House Bill 1363
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposer press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house attend to say the
vote 95 voting a 186 voting a 1363 is
laid on the
table majority committee on finance to
which was referred House Bill 1394 FNA
an act relative to lure and regulation
of Music therapists and making an
appropriation therefore consider the
same report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with amendment in Jose
camberis for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
jrh for the minority of the committee
the amendment is 1441h printed in house
record 14 page
32 uh are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those those
against they no
nay the eyes have it and the bill now
before us is ought to pass with
Amendment represent of Granger has
requested a roll call is that that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote
e
the motion before us is aut to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 1394 FNA this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
oppos you press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
house will be in order
if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 195 voting a 187 voting
a committee report is
adopted committee on finance to which
was referred house bills 1466 FN act
relative to providing disaster relief
funding to municipal ities after a
natural disaster consider the same
report the same the recommendation of
Bill ought to pass sen Mary Heath for
the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those against
nay the eyes have it your committee
report is
adopted committee on finance to which
was referred House Bill 1468 FNA act
directing the Department of
Transportation to develop a Conway
Branch rail line master plan consider
the same report the same with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
Senor th buo for the committee are you
ready for the question all all in favor
say I I those oppos
nay the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted representative
leechman Dev uh didn't vote devel a
conflict of
interest on finance to which was
referred House Bill 1564 FN act relative
to child support guidelines having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation to Bill ought to pass
Senate Morin Mooney for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay the
eyes have it committee report is
adopted committee on finance to which
was referred House Bill 1570 FNA local
an act requiring the the Department of
Education to conduct a facility
assessment of public schools and public
chared schools consider the same report
the same the following Amendment a
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen of Daniel papichi
Mueller for the committee the amendment
is 1037 printed in house record 14 page
33 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
oppos nay the eyes have it amendment is
adopted motion before us now is ought to
pass with Amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I
suppose nay the guys have it and the
committee report is
adopted
am
majority of the committee on finance to
which was referred House Bill 1573 FN
act relative to oversight of and
criteria for res residential placement
of children having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation Bill ought
to pass with Amendment sen Keith Earth
for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment Mary Jane walner for the
minority of the committee majority
committee amendment is
139h printed in house record 14 pages 33
through 34 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I those oppos nay the eyes
have it the amendment is adopted bills
on second reading open to further
Amendment representative walner offers
four Amendment 1472 H and is recognized
to speak to her
Amendment
thank you Mr
Speaker we just passed an amendment that
provides $1 million to the Department of
Health and Human Services to enhance
their ability to monitor placements of
children in that are in state custody
and have been placed in residential
facilities many of these residential
facilities are out of state the floor
amendment requires the department to
report to the legislature quarterly
about how the $1 million is being spent
and the number of children in
residential care and the
report the number of visits the
department is making to the children in
residential care the information will be
really useful to the finance committee
next year as the budget in this area is
being developed thank you and I urge you
to vote
Yes jerck and he representative
Edwards uh thank you Mr Mr Speaker uh Mr
Speaker if I knew that uh I I'm really
very appreciative of a representative
the representative who just spoke uh
putting in this floor Amendment and that
it has the support of the the chair and
others in the committee would I now uh
vote
green the motion before us is the wer
floor Amendment 1472 are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the floor amendment is adopted motion
before us now is ought to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I suppose nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted majority of the committee on
finance to which was referred House Bill
1577 FN act relative to digital images
of ballots consider the same report the
same with the following Amendment the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
with Amendment s Dan Maguire from the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same in N agree
with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate sen Karen eel
for the minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise to make a motion Mr Speaker
State your motion um I move to table HB
1577 and I'd like a division vote
please evil moves the table H Bill
this is going to be a division
vote representative H requests a roll
call that is sufficiently
seconded
for
the motion before us is the table H Bill
1577 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recogniz the house will be in
order chair recognize representative
Lane for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the Secretary of State strongly
opposes this bill and if I know that
there are already
alternative methods in place to audit
ballot counting machines then would I
now push the green button to table this
unnecessary bill and I ask for division
vote chair recognize representative
Barry for a parliamentary thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
proposed amendment to this bill actually
improves the bill removing the financial
cost and Mr Speaker if I know that this
will be the ultimate form of a citizen's
audit would I press the red button to
oppose the tabling
motion the motion before us is the table
House Bill 1577 this a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you're oppos or press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend to state of the
vote 193 voting a 188 voting a house
bill 157 S L on the
table majority committee on finance to
which was referred House Bill 1583 FNA
an act relative to to per pupil cost of
an opportunity for an adult adequate
education having considered the same
report the same the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass representative
Tracy emrich for the
committee minority of the committee have
been considered the same and being
unable to agree with a majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill be
referred for inm study represent Jr holf
and the minority of the
committee for what reason to member rise
to make a motion take a state your
motion to table
1583 the motion is the table H Bill 1583
FNA I a division has been
requested
who requested the roll
call it is sufficiently second and we
just
need not
yet
the motion before us is to table House
Bill
1583 this is going to be roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Emerich
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you m thank you Mr Speaker
if I know many of the provisions in 1583
are being handled by the governor's hold
harmless for uh financially strapped
communities would I would I now vote to
table this
bill chair recognize representative
Heath for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this is part of a
bipartisan bill that came to us as a
result of the special subcommittee
bipartisan subcommittee that worked
together and if I further know this is
the first step to bring funds to our
school districts in response to this the
court
orders I would ask you to vote red no
not to table this Bill thank thank you
very
much motion before us is a table House
Bill 1583 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of your opposer press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
repr I can't see
repres
if all members present have an
opportunity to vote house attend to stay
to the
vote 180 voting a 2011 voting a the
motion
fails now we're back to ought to
pass are are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppos
n okay we only need one the vision has
been called for
clarification only those in the
chamber the motion before us is a
clarification vote on House Bill 1583
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 205 voting a 177 voting a commit
report
adoped committee on finance to which was
referred House Bill 1588 FN an act
relative to court jurisdiction over
persons receiving special education
consider the same report the same with
the following Amendment a recommendation
Bill ought to pass with Amendment pres
of David priest for the committee the
amendment is 1391 H printed in house
record 14 page 39 you for the question
on the amendment all those in favor say
I I oppos nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is a of pass with Amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the committee report is
adopted committee on finance to which
was referred houseal Bill 1589 FN act
establishing a veterans treatment Court
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment a
recommendation Bill ought to pass with
Amendment sen Dan McGuire for the
committee the amendment is
13968 printed in house record 14 pages
39 and 40 you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
oppos nay the eyes have it the amendment
is adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment are you
ready for question all those in favor
say I iose nay the eyes have it and
committee report is
adopted
the committee on finance to which was
referred House Bill 1593 FN an act
making an appropriation of the
Department of Health and Human Services
to support recreational activities for
individuals with developmental
disabilities having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Jerry Stringham for the
committee Amendment 1161 H is printed on
house record 14 on pages 40 to 41
questions on the amendment you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those oppose
nay and the amendment's adopted now the
question is all to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the report is
adopted the majority of the committee on
finance to which is referred House Bill
1595 FN an act relative to adjustment of
the child support guidelines based on
parenting time medical support and child
care expenses having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Jess Edwards for the
majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
representative Laura tersi for the
minority of the
committee question is on Amendment
1178 H which is printed in house record
14 on page 41 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oos May
no we're going to do a clarification
vote keep the doors
closed
all right if you're in favor of adopting
the amendment press the green button if
you're opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
[Music]
mark have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 197 in the affirmative and 177 very
loud Nays the Amendments
adopted now the question is the majority
report of ought to pass with
Amendment representative Gibbons is
recognized to speak for the committee
report
thank you Mr Speaker um House Bill 19 or
1595 uh it comes with bipartisan legis
um recommendations from the original
committee I was the one from from the
Democrat side that supported it um this
the formula is supported by our judges
it's supported by attorneys it is
supported by um the Bureau of child
support services staff and parents that
were surveyed um New Hampshire is one of
nine states without a similar formula so
we have data that this works uh there is
some argument that there could be uh
problems in domestic violence
relationships we have not seen that in
the studies that we went over all summer
long um I would recommend that you vote
for this bill um it can work in hand
with House Bill 1564 which was already
passed uh they are separate but they are
related and they can work together thank
you representative cherski is recognized
to speak against the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker
division three of house finance had two
bills before us that both addressed the
issue of child
support because the bills each had
similar fiscal notes for system updates
some members of the division believed
both could be passed with the fiscal
impact of just one bill House Bill 1564
passed this body earlier today and came
out of the policy committee unanimously
with strong bipartisan support this bill
House Bill 15 1995 also deals with child
support but questions
remain advocates for families and
children like Waypoint New Hampshire
Association of justice and New Hampshire
Legal Assistant all expressed serious
concerns with how the bill addresses
unique situations where abuse
exists the bottom line is House Bill
1595 relies on parenting time in the
calculation of child support and that in
and of itself is inherently problematic
in cases of domestic violence or
situations of
abuse making a direct connection between
parenting time and support is highly
concerning and putting a premium on
parenting time sets up situations ripe
for abuse and does not put the child's
well-being Above All Else due to the
complexities around the issue the
minority of the committee believes it
would be more prudent to interim study
House Bill 1595 to fully understand the
impact of the bill this bill will have a
significant change on determining child
support but we need to be sure that
vulnerable children won't be at risk the
bill needs to SC be scrutinized further
to ensure without question that the
well-being of every child is first and
foremost in all
situations please join me in pushing the
red button to overturn the ought to pass
as amended motion so another motion can
be made and I ask for a division vote
thank you Mr
Speaker representative Edwards is
recognize to speak for the committee
report uh thank you Mr Speaker uh I
think what division did uh three did was
uh actually not out of incompetence but
uh Brilliance I'll say because what we
noticed was uh 1564 and
1595 affected the same it system and
because it would have affected the same
it system what we recognized was that uh
the the cost to do 1564 and
1595 uh were the same and so since we
passed 1564 on a Voice vote essentially
1595 no longer has a financial
implication because it's free so that
was not incompetence that was done
intentionally and for good reason the
what the amendment you just voted for
did is it agreed with 59 95 and 1564
took the definitions out of 1564 and
brought them into 1595 to be in
accordance with one another and it
established after years and years of
independent reports cost of about
$400,000 total that there ought to be an
independent uh formula involved so that
in these very uh confrontational periods
of time in the family court system that
there is some basis upon which the cost
allocation between parents is shared in
a parent co-sharing Arrangement and so
as a starting point not the conclusion
point is that has been left to float out
there as a starting point the formula
provides everyone with a common view of
what would be fair in this in this case
and then the as always the judge has the
discretion to make whatever
determination he or she wants for the
best interests of the child this this
bill has been in being made now for two
three terms uh we're right there let's
get this uh formula in so so that Family
Court can be less hellish than it is now
so please vote green on the
otpa thank
you a division votes been requested this
will be a division vote members please
take your
seats
for
questions on the majority committee
report of about to pass as amended this
is a division vote representative money
is recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker colleagues if I
know that we need to update our child
support guidelines to more clearly
address shared parenting for parents but
this bill is overly complicated making
it difficult for many self-represented
parents to use and could cause more
drawn out custom
disputes and if I know that house bill
1564 which we just passed overwhelmingly
unanimously is simpler fairer and
addresses issues that have been
lingering on this very subject since
2018 lastly if I know that we should be
decisive when spending State funds and
therefore send only one good bill to the
other side of the wall rather than two
potentially conflicting
bills then would I press the red button
so that an inim study motion can be made
thank
you representative wer is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that house bill 1595 is important for a
formula that it contains that is well
supported by all the courts and if I
know that the opposition to it wants it
to delve more into domestic violence
which was not a subject before us in
this bill what I now press the green
button to bring that very important uh
formula to law thank
you we're in the middle of a
vote the question is on the majority
committee report of ought to pass as
amended and this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppose press the red voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the vote 190 in
the affirmative 193 in the negative the
motion
fails representative Ki
moves interim study are you ready for
the question okay representative whole
request a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
e
questions on the motion of inm study on
House Bill 1595 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
e of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 208 in the affirmative 176 in a
negative the motion's
adopted the committee on finance to
which was referred House Bill 1598 FNA
an act relative to the Department of
Health and Human Services management of
Social Security payments and veterans
benefits for children in foster care
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommendation that the bill AA pass
with Amendment representative Mary Jane
walner for the committee the amendment
is
138h printed on house record 14 on page
41 the questions on the adoption of the
amendment you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the Amendments
adopted now the question is the main
motion of ought to pass as amended are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I
all those oppos nay the eyes have it and
then reports
adopted
the majority of the committee on finance
to which was referred Al Bill 1633 FNA
an act relative to the legalization of
regulation of cannabis and making appr
rations therefore having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Chuck crassi for the
majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
it as inexpedient to legislate
representative Kenneth Wier for the
minority of the
committee the questions on the adoption
of amendment
1393 H printed in house record 4 14 on
pages 41-
52 you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I all those oose nay the
eyes have it and the Amendments
adopted bills on second reading and open
to further Amendment representative Leon
moves floor Amendment
1446 H which is in your seat pockets and
is recognized to speak to a
motion thank you Mr Speaker this floor
floor amendment is 2 in long not 2 in
thick it is a correct some language that
in committee we clarified that the rul
making would be just um have some
distrct control I had accidentally used
the F-word franchise but it's an agency
model so that's corrected the other is
to be fair to cities so that if they're
voting in the future they won't be have
to wait until the next state election
they'll be able to vote in the next next
election if they turn it down the first
time so I'd ask for your support on this
floor Amendment thank
you the questions on the adoption of the
the amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay no the eyes have it and
the Amendments
adopted now we are on to the main motion
of ought to pass as
amended representative Wilder's
recognized speak against the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to
oppose any legalization of cannabis also
known as
marijuana we now have the examples of
many other states that have legalized
this substance over the past few years
have any of them bragged about how much
money they made have any of them seen a
reduction in petty
crime we have a system of alternative
treatment centers that are now serving
14,000 patients who have prescriptions
for the
drug casual use has caused problem
problems especially for our youth States
legalizing this substance report
increases in gang activities and violent
crime as well as problems in mental
health and Highway Safety they have not
eliminated the illegal black market and
the drug especially when they place a
tax on it to raise
revenue I read that the state of Oregon
is having second thoughts and is making
changes in
enforcement we remember will suspend for
a minute
wicked noisy so if we're leaving let's
try to leave quietly and then talk once
the doors are closed back there
continue we have witnessed enough second
thoughts in states that legalize
marijuana to realize that this is no
route for New Hampshire to follow down
that rat hole please vote no on this
Bill thank
you represent representative Ford's Rec
speak against the
report thank you Mr
speaker thank you
colleagues I rise today to speak
against uh
1633 my reasons are both personal and if
you will health
related I happen to have a sister
who has prefrontal
dementia as a sequence to using
marijuana regularly for a number of
years I won't get into the arguments
about causality or whatever it's very
technical and I'm not sure it's
conclusive but the consequence is that
what was once a vibrant young
mother is now a person who needs a
full-time personal care
attendant she does not recognize her own
grandchildren when they gathered with
her at Christmas they asked does Grandma
know we're here does she know my name
why doesn't she hug me
back she does not even know she is
married can you
imagine being married to someone
who doesn't even recognize
you and her family still cares for her
she needs that constant
attention therefore I would urge you to
think very
seriously about making
accessible and this is not a distant in
the past oldtime kind of marijuana this
is
current she's still
living
but when you get together at Christmas
she walks past you as though you were a
person on the
street she doesn't even know who her own
brother
is she knows no
one without affect totally without
affect and without affect there's no
affection there is no
recognition I can not in any way imagine
approving of access to a substance that
could even what causal or not bring
about that
consequence and therefore I cannot
support this
bill representative lon's recognized
speak for the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker no matter
what we do today and no matter what
ultimately happens with this bill there
are a large number of people in New
Hampshire that use cannabis telling them
it's illegal and they shouldn't use it
hasn't worked so I'm not sure how that
will stop anybody from using
cannabis moving to a discussion about
why children shouldn't use it because of
the brain development is a lot more
honest conversation when you can talk
about the science instead of just saying
it's illegal don't do
it the problem right now is a lot of
people who choose to use cannabis um
either either can drive out of state
they can illegally grow it at home or
they can buy it on the streets and
there's issues with buying it on the
streets what this bill would change is
you could have regulated tested product
that's free of contaminants and that is
not mixed with other drugs you would
know what was in it you would know what
strain you would know what concentration
so for those who would choose to do it
it would be
safer and for everybody else it wouldn't
be a discussion that you're having
because most people who would use
cannabis if it's legal already are the
rule followers aren't going to be the
problem but let's talk a little bit
about what this bill specifically does
this meets just about every requirement
every requirement that was previously
laid out in order to become law there
was a last minute change to require a
franchise where the language required
that the FR it seemed that the franchise
agreements would be done in secret this
bill makes it so that the agency model
has strong control but those rules about
how they operate would be done through
administrative rules so there'd be
public comment it also doesn't set
prices I think this is an excellent Bill
and quite frankly I think it's time for
us to go ahead and vote on this bill and
let the other body deal with it so I'd
appreciate your vote thank
[Music]
you representative kahill request a v
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded the this will be a
roll call vote members take your
seats
the
e
Let's go people find your
seats question is on the majority
committee report ought to pass as
amended on House Bill
settle down representative wer is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if a few years from now we begin
to experience the problems that all the
other states that have legalized this
begin to experience with youth problems
traffic problems and all of a sudden
those of you who the member will whoa
that was loud the member will suspend
you recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry will I then be happy that I am
not on the list that approved this thank
you representative Lon is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this legislation learns from the
states that have gone before us and if I
know that it's high time to pass
cannabis legalization would I then press
the green
button
questions on the majority committee
report about to pass as amended on House
Bill 1633 and this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppose press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
have all was present had an opportunity
to vote the house will attend to the
state of the
vote 239 in the affirmative 136 and the
negative the report is
adopted representative Richards declared
a conflict and did not
participate the committee on finance to
which is referred Al spell 6 1647 FNA an
act relative to the calculation of group
two retirement benefits in the
retirement system having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Gerald Griffin for the
committee the amendment is 1134 H
printed on house record 14 on page 52
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I all
those oppos nay the eyes have it and the
Amendments adopted
now on to the main motion of O to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppos nay the eyes have it and the
report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on finance
to which was referred House Bill 1649 FN
an act relative to prohibiting certain
products with intentionally added pasas
having consider the same report the same
with the following Amendment and the
recommendation at the bill ought to pass
with Amendment representative Karen eel
from the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Dan Maguire for the minority of the
committee the majority amendment is
1086 H printed in house record 14 on
page
52 this this will be a division vote on
the amendment members take your
seats
e
the questions on the adoption of
amendment 1086 H representative Dan
Maguire is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
I if I know that this amendment moves
merely moves the implementation date of
this regulation forward 18
months and if I know it's been said that
our finance committee should not be
involved in making policy changes
and if I know that there's no Financial
reason to implement this regulation
sooner and if I know that any purported
savings by extra regulation are purely
fanciful would I then press the red
button to support the policy decision of
the Commerce
Committee thank representative eel's
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that HB 1649 is amended by Commerce
removed many manufacturer requirements
leading up to the original effective
date of the ban of the sale of consumer
products with intentionally added
pasas and if I know that an earlier
effective date of the prohibition better
protects Public Health which is critical
in the face of widespread pasas
contamination and if I know that the EPA
issued new tighter P Water maximum
contaminant levels just yesterday that
will be expensive to comply with so
starting to remove pasas from consumer
products earlier could help with
reducing the P load reducing
expense would I now press the green
button to support the bipartisan
recommendation of the finance committee
and pass the committee Amendment
1086 thank you very
much the question the questions on the
adoption of amendment 1086 H as a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppos press the red
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 233 and the affirmative 147 and
negative the Amendments adopted bill is
on second reading and open to further
Amendment representative Dan Maguire
moves floor Amendment
1459 which
is in your seat
Pockets represent Maguire's recognized
speak to his
motion thank you Mr
Speaker House Bill 1649 is is too
broad it not only affects the nasty
stuff that's causing problems in marac
but it sweeps along thousands of other
things that are only marginally related
to those
chemicals when we considered this bill
in the finance committee we were told
several times that the bill is not
breaking new ground that it's just
implementing bands that already exist in
other
states I investigated what the state of
California is doing in this area and
California is a state with over 25 times
our
population and it correspondingly has a
much larger
Dees and much more capability of
environmental
regulation they have a large enough
market that manufacturers and retailers
will cater to their their
regulations we do
not if we enact honorous regulation
producers May simply quit our
Market this is particularly true if we
enact regulation that is in excess of
what California
does this amendment concerns the
paragraph in the bill that defines food
packaging to be
banned it is word for word what
California has in their P
laws it regulates mostly disposable
paper and cardboard items that contain
food and beverage like bags cups and
boxes and it also includes utensils and
straws these items according to the FDA
are the primary source of pasas in the
diet the FDA announced this past
February that grease prooof substances
with pasas like those found in French
fry boxes sandwich wrappers microwave
popcorn bags coffee cups and so on are
no longer sold in the United
States the problem with the food
packaging language as exists in House
Bill
1649 is that it goes far far beyond what
California and the FDA are
regulating it regulates the outside of
the container and the outside of the
shipping
carton uh as much as the
inside it specifically regulates labels
and the inks used to print them on every
food and beverage box can bottle and bag
found in the the grocery
store strangely it it doesn't regulate
labels and ink on anything else like
toothpaste or shampoo or cleaning
products
okay
PTFE which is the chemical name for
teflon is widely used in the printing
industry in inks and
Coatings it's what gives printed
material it's rub
resistance when you handle a can in the
grocery store the ink doesn't come off
on your fingers that's frequently the
the um result of Teflon being used in
the ink or in the
coating but Teflon is included in the
house bill 1649 definition of past to be
banned even though Teflon is not a
harmful chemical
if we
keep we'll talk about that more on the
next Amendment but yes um if we keep
house will be in order the member has a
right to be heard and we're not supposed
to
react thank you Mr Speaker if we keep
House Bill
1649 definition of food containers as
including labels and
ink we could be banning every item on
grocery store shelves
today please press the green button
thank you Mr
Speaker representative eil recognize
speak against the
amendment thank you Mr
Speaker I urge this body to reject this
floor Amendment proposing to amend the
definition of food packaging this
definition and this bill were fully
vetted by the policy committee the house
Commerce Committee and passed by this
house on a Voice vote without debate to
change this def this definition now at
this late dat is ill advised and
unwise during our finance committee work
sessions not one person testified
against this bill and certainly no one
took issue with the definition of food
packaging the current HB 1649 definition
is the policy position of the house food
packaging is is one of the leading ways
in which we're all exposed to
pasas and that is why food packaging is
included in this bill pasts are in many
forms of packaging from microwave
popcorn to french fry bags to paper
plates because of their anti-stick
properties and while it is true the
predominant use of pasas in food
packaging is in connection with Paper
Products
Research also indicates that this is not
the exclusive use of pasas in packaging
and there are more States than
California that ban food packaging when
you look at the other definitions in the
other
state this bill focuses on the
intentional addition of PAs to Consumer
products in Communications I have had
with industry Representatives we agreed
that the current definition of food
packaging was acceptable
as the focus of this bill is
intentionally added
pasas this is certainly no time to be
amending the definition of food
packaging or anything else in this bill
and especially not with respect to an
item that has the potential of so much
consumption like many bills this
legislation has several moving parts and
one relies upon the other for complete
common sense piece PE uh of of
legislation for these reasons I urge
this body to support the diligent policy
work of the Commerce
Committee uphold the strong vote of this
house and support the recommendation of
the finance committee and press the red
button to reject this amendment and Mr
Speaker I request a roll call
vote representative eiles requested a
roll call vote is that sufficiently
seconded
that is sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote members take your
seats
e
questions on the adoption of amendment
1459 H this is a roll call vote
representative Aman is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the FDA and other
big Regulators are already eliminating P
from food
packaging and if I know that not even
California is attempting to regulate ink
on labels and shipping
boxes and if I don't want to take the
chance that grocery store shelves will
be bar due to lack of compliant
packaging what I now press the green
button to bring us back to a more
sensible level of Regulation that
California has adopted for food
packaging representative eeles
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the FDA um announcement that's
being referred to only apply to three
manufacturers of food processing and
there are others if I know that the
definition of p was fully vetted and
recommended by the policy committee
house Commerce passed by this house and
supported by the finance
committee if I know changing a
foundational definition here on the
floor without vetting whatsoever or
public input is ill advised ized and
unwise and is less protective to the
public
health um and wait I'm on the I need to
find my other page okay if I know that
some food packaging can contain unwanted
p and by amending this definition P
added ban would only apply to Paper
Products excluding those products
exposing us to more of these hazardous
chemicals and if I know that the point
of this bill is to protect the public
health and stem the tide of pasas in our
water air and soils and by changing this
definition more pasas added products can
accumulate in our landfills only to
leech out later would I now press the
red button and reflect and reject this
floor
Amendment questions on the adoption of
amendment 1459 H this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
Rosen
Buy
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house Li
attendant the state of the
vote 165 and the affirmative 216 and
negative the amendment
fails the bill is on second reading and
open a further Amendment and Maguire
offers floor
Amendment
1460 which is in your seat
pockets for what reason does a member
rise make a motion I'm sorry to make a
motion what's your motion I would like
to request that the comments from the
last debate be entered into the
permanent
journal and you might want to wait till
the
end all
righty representative eel's recogniz
speak against the
amendment
that's right you
have
okay Mr Speaker I urge this body to
reject this floor amendment to change
the definition of
p this change basically eviscerates the
protections of HB
1649 by severely limiting the types of P
molecules that would be banned for use
in our everyday products by making the
definition far more limited many fewer P
added products will be banned and we
will be left not much better off than we
are now this definition looks backward
not forward PF OS pfna and PF
OA are already being used less by
manufacturers because of their hazards
but that doesn't mean manufacturers have
stopped using pasas these versions of
pasas are simply replaced with another
configuration of pasas and that my
colleagues is exactly the problem this
is like a game of whack-a-mole to
achieve the goal of this legislation we
need to look ahead not behind and that
takes a prod definition that is now
included in this bill we need the broad
definition of p to ensure that by
changing a hydrogen here or an oxygen
there the P created don't fall outside
the
definition the focus has to be on the
thing that makes these chemicals so
dangerous and that is the unbreakable
carbon flooring Bond and no matter how
you dress it up the health hazards
remain like putting lipstick on a past
Pig this is precisely the analysis that
was done by the house Commerce Committee
which looked at this closely because the
definition is one of the Cornerstone
pieces of this
legislation the broader definition now
in the bill is what the Commerce
Committee
recommended why would we completely
ignore their analysis and what is the
point of a policy committee working with
the chair of Commerce certain items were
excluded from the bill while leaving the
definition intact and I will say before
the final vote the chair asked multiple
times if there were other Industry Group
that has concerns or needed exclusion
the room had many lobbyists not one
person responded and I'm told as of
yesterday no one has reached
out it's Folly to change the definition
now at this late date here on the floor
when this version was never once
discussed either in Commerce or in
finance in fact another definition of
pasas was also rejected that was
proposed by my friend from from Epsom it
too was rejected as too restrictive and
it was actually less restrictive than
this one is and not aligned with the
policy position adopted by the house not
one person requested this during our
work sessions or spoke against the bill
the harmful health effects are
undeniable why have a more restrictive
definition when there is really so much
at stake even the EPA has now imposed
Nationwide drinking water standards for
a more expanded list of P than what's
being proposed in this
amendment the broader definition is
protective of the public health it
anticipates future changes to the Past
molecules by
manufacturers and is in fact the
standard definition for such bands used
in many other states and the Department
of Defense it is also the definition of
already in our own New Hampshire
statutes as part of our existing ban of
pasas in firefighting foam we were in
the Vanguard adopting that uh
Prohibition in
2020 manufacturers actually like
consistency and they should not have to
comply with different different past
definitions in different states and
certainly not just for our small state
then they have to comply with elsewhere
Ware such a change would also complic
complicate the development of a
compliance clearing house and make it
more
expensive I urge this body on this basis
to reject this unnecessary and unwise
floor amendment by pressing the red
button and Mr Speaker I again request a
roll call
vote representative Dan Maguire is
recognized to speak for the
amendment
thank you Mr Speaker I actually agree
with part of that but I'll get to it in
a minute um this amendment changes the
definition of pasas used in the bill
which currently in the bill is a class
of fluorinated organic chemicals
containing at least one fully
fluorinated carbon meaning one carbon
atom that has one or two flines off of
it and it changes it to the somewhat
lengthier list that you see in your seat
pocket in front of you on on Amendment
1468 the problem with the definition
used in the bill is that it's this broad
it's huge and it describes some
15,000 useful chemical compounds many of
which are known not to be
harmful for example over a 100
prescription
medications including proac and
lipor uh which is now a generic it's off
patent called
atorvastatin which is the number one
prescription drug in the United States
with 120 million prescriptions issued
per year meets the definition of pasas
inhouse Bill
1649 now I would argue that medications
medications are exempt from 1649 by the
way right so the bill does not um ban
medications but I would argue that
medications are among the most tested
and
safest uh
items in the world right I mean these
These are thoroughly
tested and uh for safety right and how
reliable is the definition we're
using if we Define as harmful things a
def we use a definition that includes
multiple prescription
drugs right doesn't make sense similarly
here we'll get to Teflon here similarly
the definition in the bill includes
Teflon which is known as
PTFE Teflon is 100% fully fluorinated
carbon atoms so the definition in House
Bill
1649 is is exactly Teflon right so if
any compound included one Teflon
molecule as part of its you know larger
molecule then it then it would be banned
okay
Teflon is widely used in implantable
devices like catheters and heart valves
and things like that it's what gives
Glide dental floss its slippery
qualities um
gortex uh it gives gortex its waterproof
quality and Teflon tape its ability to
seal pipe
connections we have already you talked
about its use in inks right it's also
found in wiring insulation and non-stick
cookware the shirt tie and shoes I'm
wearing today meet the definition of
pest in the bill
okay
strangely none of those things I just
mentioned including my shirt and so on
are regulated by this
bill uh but what is banned is any
tablecloth drape sheet upholstery carpet
or textile treatment that includes
Teflon this means that much of what is
on the market today that is stain
resistant or waterproof in those
categories will be banned by this bill
to narrow the definition of pest to
actually harmful chemicals I again
turned to
California for many years California has
had a labeling law called Proposition 65
you may have seen products labeled for
the California Market that say something
like uh Proposition 65 warning this
product contains some chemical known to
the state of California to cause cancer
or birth defects or
whatever those warnings are on anything
that contains any item on a list of
dangerous
chemicals that list is 22 pages long it
has hundreds and hundreds of chemicals
on
it what you see in this amendment in
front of you are all the pasas items
from that
list right
so um
verbatim they include the the two
harmful chemicals found in
marac right plus a plus another one and
all directly related
compounds but they do not include Teflon
gortex or Lipitor none of which gets a
warning label in
California all right the advantage of
using this definition besides targeting
chemicals that are actually harmful is
that producers already know which of
their products require a California
warning and which
don't um if those products are in
categories banned by House Bill
1649 then they couldn't be sold in in
New
Hampshire but manufacturers would not
have to do anything special for
us um as they would with the with the
definition now in the bill and they
would have an easier time uh complying
with our
regulations but I would like to be
clear California has adopted some
bans including on cosmetics and toys and
a few other things that use the
definition that's currently in House
Bill
1649 okay those bans have not yet gone
into
effect right just like House Bill 1649
pushes off the effective date so does
California and I think that California
made a mistake by Banning things that
they themselves do not think deserves a
health
warning right the very the very breth of
that legislation has caused California's
governor Nome to veto some past bills
passed by his
legislature I don't think that the
sponsors of House Bill 1649 would like
to have the same fate happen to it
please press the green button does a
member yield for a question yes I
representative hole you may
inquire thank you Mr Speaker I'll make
it a quick question if the harm for
these chemicals is truly about getting
inside the
body and the bill talks about packaging
but not
cookware talks about gortex fabric
clothes and carpets but doesn't talk
about implantable medical devices are we
going the correct Direction with this
Bill thank you for the question
representative obviously my my opinion
is
no representative eiles recognized speak
against the
amendment oh you want it ready my bad
representative Bill Boyd is recognized
to speak against the
amendment thank you Mr
Speaker and Mr Speaker through you to my
esteemed colleagues of the New Hampshire
General Court
today I rise in opposition to the
proposed amendment 1460 H the amendment
removes Gen X and F floex sulfonic acid
from the pro proposed Bill eliminating
the definition and the remedy the
language seeks to establish to protect
Granite State
groundwater as we all know New
Hampshire's ground water becomes the
source water that percolates through our
strata into our stream and rivers
artisian Wells ponds and lakes they
remain our primary sources for drinking
water now I chair the New Hampshire
drinking water and groundwater advisory
commission which was tasked under RSA
485 hyphen f colon 3 to investigate
manage and remediate contaminated and
polluted groundwater while administering
a trust fund of
$277 million acquired in 2016 from the
state's Exon Mobile settlement since
then the commission has leveraged over
$180 million in Grant and Loans in
support of municipalities and Village
districts goals of cleaning water and
improving water access to its
users communities like wendam Salem
Jaffrey Peterboro Conway Rochester and
Winchester to name a few have benefited
from the funding provided ed through the
Drinking Water
Commission we've allocated $9.5 million
in Source water protection to
communities like West Morland and
Kingston and North umberland we've
allocated $5 million for a posos rebate
program for private well owners to
implement a point of entry treatment
system for their homes and it doesn't
even begin to scratch the surface of
other allocations that came from our
general fund in support of existing
Statewide water revolving funds ARA
money and the recent news of Federal
grant money coming to New Hampshire in
the amount of $9.7 million to treat
Posas and our water the commitment to
invest millions of dollars into
providing access to clean portable water
to all granted stat is
evident now I asked the question based
on the data that I've
presented why are we investing all this
money to remediate p and other
pollutants in our drinking water but
we're allowing these posos forever
chemicals to permeate unfettered in our
land fills which filter down its way
into our
groundwater this fi these financial
investments that we've been making run
contrary to our
actions this floor Amendment as
presented removes two key chemical
compounds from the bill which would
curtail any meaningful rule to control
these chemicals in our solways from
leeching into our groundwater voting
against this amendment will permit the
underlying Bill to offer a significant
first step to tackling products with
posos while allowing the state The
Village districts and municipalities to
plan budget and manage cost associated
with solid waste removal and clean
drinking
water water is an invaluable commodity
that is driving the hress economic
growth housing opportunities and
Community Public Health if we as a
legislative
body remain serious in addressing these
issues then we must remain Vigilant in
tackling this issue headon I sincerely
ask that you reject the floor amendment
by pressing the red button to ensure we
as citizen legislators promote clean
water for the communities that we
represent thank you Mr
Speaker representative eiles requested a
roll call vote is that sufficiently
seconded
that is sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote members take your
seats
for
questions on the adoption of floor
Amendment 146 and this is a roll call
vote representative ammon's recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you again Mr
Speaker if I know that this this bill's
definition of past includes over 10,000
useful
substances if I know that among those
are compounds in lipor proac Teflon
gortex and many other safe items and if
I know that this amendment reduces that
list to the known harmful compounds that
California warns against that have
caused problems in marac and that our DS
regulates in drinking water would I now
press the green button to make this
regulation manageable thank you
representative eeles recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry if I know that the definition of
pasas was fully vetted and recommended
by the policy committee house Commerce
passed by this house and supported by
the finance committee if I know that
changing a foundational definition here
on the floor without any vetting
whatsoever which was not requested
during any hearing and there has been no
public ill input is ill-advised and
unwise and far less protective of Public
Health and if Fino manufacturers are
already familiar with and will be
following the definition in HB 1649
because that's what is used in similar
bands across the United States more than
in just
California and the new definition simply
complicates this bill and makes it more
expensive for manufacturers and for Dees
when it establishes the compliance
Clearing House would I now press the red
button and reject this floor Amendment
the question is on the adoption of
amendment 1468 it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppose press the red voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present and an opportunity
to vote house will attend to the state
of the vote 156 in the affirmative 223
in the negative the amendment
fails what reason do member rise rise to
make a motion go ahead I move to uh
table House Bill
representative representative verbal
moves that house bill 1649 be laid on
the
table representative evil requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
Yep this will be a roll call vote
members take your
seats
e
question is whether the L House Bill
1649 on the
table representative veral is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that laws and regulations like
this
are really the purview of the federal
government and are better handled by the
federal EPA to give us National
uniformity in rules for consistency to
businesses as other speakers have
actually called for
earlier if I know that legislation that
goes to ban substances should be banning
substances that are
bioaccumulative or
toxic or bioaccumulative and toxic but
not entire classes of compounds that
number currently into the tens of
thousands and Mr Speaker if I
know that industry in the United States
today is already working diligently
towards past free products because the
state of Maine two years ago passed the
most restrictive P law in the nation and
so to be able to produce and sell a
product in all 50 states you would have
to adhere to the main
regulations so if I know that that would
make this bill redundant and make it
more complicated for businesses involved
in inter State Commerce would I now
press the green button to table this
bill so we can move on uh with the rest
of our business today thank you Mr
Speaker representative evil recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that there is intense
concern and interest in the state of New
Hampshire in existing P contamination
especially in marac where they've had
the biggest environmental disaster in
the state of New Hampshire because of
contamination if I know that New
Hampshire doesn't only regulate the way
other states do New Hampshire takes
actions that make sense to
it if I know that even though we've been
discussing amendments just far on the
bill we haven't yet really had the
opportunity to discuss one of the most
important bills um I would say that
we're talking about today considering
the interest in this issue would I now
press the red button for the public
health uh benefits that a further
discussion of this uh Bill and its
passage could uh reveal thank you
questions whether lay House Bill 1649 on
the table it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppos press the red voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 165 and the affirmative 215 and the
negative the motion
fails now we are on to the main motion
finally of a to pass as
amended representative Carol Browns
recognized to speak against the
committee
report uh thank you Mr Speaker I'm going
to touch on a few different topics
around this bill I was asked to give you
a little background of of some of my
experience in this
I worked for Dees for 30 years I worked
a good portion of that time in this hang
on a sec thank you let's just let him
go I've often wondered what it feels
like to have everyone walk out on you
when you're up
here
really
I don't know what's going on here but
whatever you're going to do do it
quickly don't gather and congregate and
have conversations over there if you're
going to get out get out and let the
member be heard this is
ridiculous sorry continue for the
members who actually do want to pay
attention uh thank you Mr Speaker again
uh I was a de Dees employee for 30 years
I worked a good portion of that time in
the super fund program which you know
super fund sites are the most highly
contaminated sites in the
country I have been on those sites I've
taken thousands of contaminated
groundwater and surface water and soil
samples I've spent a considerable amount
of time at the dairy landfill the old
dairy landfill
deciding uh for EPA whether that should
be on the super fund list turns out that
it was
not um I've performed site assessments
for a number of other sites to see if
they would qualify for the super fund
list I've also managed the remediation
of several hazardous was
sites and oil and gas contaminated sites
so I think I maybe have a little bit
more perspective to give this to give to
you for this
so I'm in opposition to this bill uh
primly because of some of the reasons
you've already heard that it's very
Broad and it takes an entire class of
compounds and lumps them into the same
category of Health
dangers let me give you an
example we have dangerous chemicals
around us every
day Benzene is a human
carcinogen and it's acutely toxic and
can cause death in the correct amounts
if you breathe it in but where is
Benzene it's in gasoline every one of
you is exposed to Benzene Vapors every
time you go to the gas station and fill
your
tank why does that not hurt
you because it's about dose it's about
how much of that have you taken in all
of
these MCL maximum contaminant levels or
water quality standard levels whatever
you'd like to call them every kind of a
standard for health is based on a dosage
what is that going to do to you how much
do you have of that have you breathed it
in or eaten it or or had to drink of
that every standard is based on some
amount of
consumption as you've heard already
today yesterday EPA came out with their
uh drinking water standards for the five
past uh constituents the same and Dees
already has it for those same uh four of
those same five those numbers are based
on the person drinking a certain amount
of that water over a certain amount of
time so it does not mean that if you're
exposed to that 10 parts per trillion
whatever the number may be whichever
whichever of those chemicals it is it
does not mean that you're going to get
ill IM immediately it doesn't even mean
that chronically you might be
contracting cancer at a later time
that's up to you to be very specifically
understanding of what these standards
mean so if you take an entire class of
chemicals and say we're going to say
they're all dangerous because we know
these
five are fairly
dangerous that's the argument you've
heard that I think that that's a overly
Broad
look at
it I'm just checking to see if I've
covered everything I've written um I
want to talk to you a little bit about
how does this get into our
environment I've heard in the last year
and a half that I've been here a number
of times and it's been said at least
twice
today
if that past if we have it in our state
it is going to go into a landfill and it
is going to go into the drinking water
through
lee8 and even if you however you vote on
this you remember this now if you would
for the future that's not
true we have six Active Municipal Solid
Waste landfills in New
Hampshire all of them are double lined
what that
means you've got the waste and you have
a very thick plastic liner on top of
that is a drainage system that collects
the leachate the
intent is that that leade does not get
to the plastic liner and even get down
to the groundwater through the
liner the lee8 is purposefully collected
so it we don't just let the liquids
build up in a landfill it's collected
and sent off site for
treatment depending where the landfill
is depends where it goes some of our
Municipal wastewater treatment plants
can take
leate because they have industrial
pre-treatment programs that know how to
manage that and as time moves on the EPA
is adjusting those discharge permits uh
to give them past
limits some of that leech a is sent off
State some is sent to New Jersey so all
of the lee8 in your landfills is being
collected let's say for sake of argument
that that first liner gets a hole in
it underneath that first liner is
another drainage
system that can detect flow
rates through the drainage system so
they can say oh look there's a lot of
flow over here in this drainage system
that could mean there's a leak up there
and then it can be excavated and
repaired
so remember this no matter how many
times someone in here says if you put
something in a landfill it's going into
the groundwater or surface water water
that just is not accurate please uh do
your homework on that if if you uh if
you uh if you don't agree with that you
know do your own
homework
um so kind of
summarize the best way I think to reduce
exposure to
pasas let me back up a little bit I I
will I'll reiterate what I said earlier
this is very broad it's a broad bill it
it includes
everything every C Every chemical in the
pest
universe and EPA and Dees have only come
up with levels for four or five of those
and that's only if you drink it that's
not if you touch it that's not if you
have it on a cup on some ink that's only
if you consume the
water so the best way to continue this I
think for the State of New Hampshire is
what FDA has already initiated as you've
heard elimin ating some of this from
food packaging but that happened in
February after the already did
that continue to properly collect and
treat Landfield
leachate and therefore that would
continue to eliminate past sources to
drinking
water therefore I would ask you to
please press the red button thank you
representative danan Maguire's
recognized speak against the
report thank you Mr Speaker when
California's governor governor Nome
vetoed the uh menstrual products ban
bill the same provision is in house bill
1649 he said quote previously enacted
single product chemical bans which also
lack oversight are proving challenging
to
implement with inconsistent
interpretations and confusion among
manufacturers about how to comply with
the
restrictions he was referring to bans on
food packaging textiles and juvenile
products all of which are included to
some degree in House Bill
1649 if California is finding these kind
of bands challenging to implement what
hope does our Dees
have to do
it the sheer number of products involved
means that enforcement is necessarily
going to be
selective and almost certainly will
Target smaller
manufacturers is Dees going to tell
Hines to change the printing on their 57
products
products no and give no not very likely
but they might very well go to a local
craft Brewer and ask them about the ink
used to print their beer
labels if their supplier can't provide
this the satisfactory
documentation there goes the whole
Brewery
business and then there's
carpet isn't it likely that stain
resistant
carpet is a huge benefit to pet
owners without it what kind of cleaning
chemicals will they have to use and how
often or or we are we going to see
carpet bootlegging from
Massachusetts who
knows we have no way of knowing the
circumstances of all manufacturers and
consumers we can't gauge the value of
any particular technology to
them chemicals like these don't come
into existence
randomly they are deliberately created
manufactured designed into products and
purchased presumably because they are
superior to any known
alternative how can we substitute our
incomplete judgments
for that of millions of
individuals wouldn't it be better to
inform people of the hazards if hazards
exist and let them make their own
decisions especially when they are the
ones most at
risk please push the red button thank
you Mr
Speaker representative eiles recognized
speak for the committee report
I'm back thank you Mr Speaker um I rise
today in support of HB
1649 an important bipartisan bill that
would ban the sale of consumer products
in New Hampshire that we use in our
everyday lives with past that have been
intentionally added by
manufacturers for forever chemicals are
made to never break down and they don't
creating havoc in their wake I urge this
body to support the finance committee's
bipartisan ought to pass as amended
recommendation on this bill and as has
been mentioned many times this follows
The house's strong Voice vote and
support and the Commerce Committee um
strong
recommendation we need to stop P
contamination in its tracks just
yesterday the EPA finally took action
requiring drinking water utilities
across the country to remove remove
certain p to no greater than four parts
per
trillion this is yet another huge wakeup
call on the extreme hazards of the
chemicals regardless of your personal
opinions of the health
effects these regulations must be
complied with and at huge expense and as
we spend unbelievable amounts of money
to remove P one wonders why the heck do
we keep using the stuff for so many
consumer products when it is a
convenience it needs to
stop surface water groundwater private
Wells waste water drinking water soil
air landfill leech a sludge left
untreated we know what all these can
have in common pasas commit
contamination liver problems thyroid
issues kidney disease decreased immunity
and maternal health hazards we know what
these health problems can result from
the people in virtually all of us it's
even in the breast milk of new mothers
it's been found and their newborns and
it's time to stop our
exposure is there another state that's
been quite as burdened by past
contamination our attorney general has
sued for millions and damages and we've
already spent about $110 million dollars
in tax tax dollars to mitigate past
contamination and there's no end in
sight so what to do it's time to focus
on the source of pasas in all our lives
these forever chemicals are in a
mindboggling number of consumer products
ensuring baby mattresses don't stain
food doesn't stick and we don't get
spaghetti stains on our easy chairs but
at what cost this bill seeks to stem the
tide of past in our lives and it brought
together a remarkable unusual group of
steak holders to support the bill
landfill operators Wastewater and
drinking water utilities public health
organizations firefighters the municipal
Association clean water Advocates and
environmental groups only the hazards of
something like pasas could bring
together such disperate groups together
with one voice and say Make It
Stop in three years man manufacturers
would be banned from selling specified
products in our state to which they've
added pasas and for the most part these
are products that are most commonly
banned in other states and more States
will soon join those States we should be
one of them the consumer products
proposed to be banned are all things we
use in our everyday lives including food
packaging infant and children products
Cosmetics carpets upholstered furniture
and textiles used in our homes they are
either sources of the most direct
exposure to us or they carry the highest
P loads into our
landfills and speaking of
landfills P from our trash flow into
landfills and then into the collected
landfill leee in the millions and
millions of gallons this toxic leachate
is truck to wastewater treatment plans
where it joins sewer and septic waste
also containing
pasas much pasas ends up back in sludge
that goes right back into the
landfills but much goes into surface and
groundw that same water is subsequently
used for drinking water where it has to
be filtered at extreme costs by our
drinking water utilities to ensure our
safety and before long many way water
treatment plants will likely have to
treat water for past before releasing it
something they don't do now our economic
burden will be even more enormous and
meanwhile manufacturers continue to use
past in the products that they sell to
us that is the definition of
insanity the costs of this bill are
minimal one Dees position and
$250,000 to get the progam program up
and running the reason that Governor
Nome vetoed the bills member can suspend
for a
second why can't we be silent and listen
to people speak there are plenty of
other places to be if that's impossible
for you let's just get through this
please continue thank you the reason
that the governor vetoed three bills
that instituted bans one of which
included uh feminine hygiene products is
because the way they passed the bills in
California there was no uh oversight of
a um agency there was simply a ban put
in place with a penalty That was
supposed to be enforced by the Attorney
General um and that was his primary
concern and that was what the issue was
in
California for the um the health impacts
and costs of past remediation and
healthc care unquantifiable for small
money Dees can join a multi multi-state
Clearing House to assess compliance
focused on manufacturers and not
retailers Dees now belongs to Interstate
Mercury and toxics and packaging clear
houses that have been in effect for a
very long time this was a particular uh
interest of the Commerce Committee when
reviewing this bill manufacturers know
how to use these CU we've already banned
these toxins that's how how these bands
are enforced and it's familiar to
business once thought of as useful these
chemicals like pasas are now recognized
as harmful not unlike DDT or mtbe
usefulness doesn't equate to safety now
it's time to take a strong stand these
forever chemicals should not be in the
air we breathe the water we drink or the
soil we walk on we may never be able to
cor correct the damage P has already
done
but now is the time to look to the
Future and stop using pasas and common
consumer products please join me by
pressing the green button to support the
bipartisan ought to pass recommendation
of the finance committee for this bill
our families our children our
grandchildren our state our world
deserve nothing less Mr Speaker I
require I request a roll call
vote representative Ranger has requested
a roll call vote is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
speak an
you
the house will come to
order the questions on the majority
committee report of OA pass as amended
on House Bill
1649 representative Ammon is recognized
for parliamentary
inquir thank you for the final time Mr
Speaker if I know that P is a subject of
intense interest to Federal Regulators
who have significantly more resources
than RDS does if I know that California
is finding implementing of these bans so
challenging their governor has vetoed
three such bills because they're
difficult to
enforce and if I know that the leech aid
from
landfills is collected and processed in
an industrial Wastewater
facility and the problems in marac were
caused by Industrial Waste not consumer
products and if I know that industrial
operators are the primary source of p in
the environment not the consumer goods
baned in this bill and if I know that
we're about to ban and this list is long
so if I know we're about to ban this
list we're about to ban carpets and rugs
Cosmetics textile treatments feminine
hygiene products food packaging and
containers juvenile products personal
protective equipment upholstered
furniture textile Furnishings that's the
list verbatim from the bill these are
items if I know these are items in most
of most of our homes and our closets and
our wardrobes what I now press the red
button so as not to misdirect our
limited DS resources thank you Mr
Speaker representative Moone is
recognized for a shorter parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker members if
I know that our state continues to
suffer environmentally and physically
from the devastating effects of p in our
water air soil and if I know that as a
result of millions of dollars spent and
hundreds upon hundreds of hours in
meetings discussions research litigation
negotiations that there is agreement
that only one action will further the
harm will limit further harm and lastly
if I know that that one action to limit
further harm is to prohibit p in certain
products as this bill
does then would I join the bipartisan
majority of the house finance committee
and vote on the green button on the
motion of ought to pass with Amendment
thank
you questions on the majority committee
report about to pass as amended on House
Bill 1649 and it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor press green button
oppose press the red voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote The House liend of
the state of the vote 233 in the
affirmative 140 in the negative the
report is adopted
Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker what reason doesn't member us uh
for a motion to place the debate in the
permanent
Journal fine we'll put it to a vote the
question is shall the previous remarks
be placed in the permanent
Journal
I got a division request will that do
it if only this will be a division vote
members take your
seats
spe
the question is whether or not to print
the remarks of the previous debate in
the permanent Journal it's a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members presentent had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote 229 and
the affirmative 148 and the negative the
remarks shall be
printed Mr
Speaker
for what reason does the member
rise to make a motion okay um Mr Speaker
I'd like to remove um house build 1212
from the
table
okay repres luno moves at House Bill
1212 be removed from the
table
okay
repr
it this is going to be a division vote
members take your
seats
anything
the motion is to remove House Bill 12
toll from the table it's going to be a
division vote chair recognize
representative hall for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that house bill 1212
provides greater access to school meals
for children and supports families
struggling to make ends meet and if I
know that half of the children in New
Hampshire live in households with
insufficient
food and if I know that an amendment to
House Bill 1212 includes a number of
compromises including reducing the
income eligibility cap from 350 to 250%
of
poverty and has a program cost of
approximately $13 million the member
will suspend this is about removing the
bill from the table not the content of
the bill
itself okay and not $50 or $100 million
I now press the green button so that we
can debate House Bill 1212 offer an
amendment and feed the kids thank
you chair recognize representative
waller for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the finance committee carefully
computed how much could be spent from
all these bills and this one was not in
that computation and if I know it is 50
$50 million extra that should not be
spent but it will imperil all the other
things we've passed what I now vote not
to take it off the table thank you push
the red
button the motion is to remove House
Bill 1212 from the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
represent Kennedy
have all members present have the
opportunity to
vote house will attain the state of the
vote 188 voting yay 189 voting nay I did
not vote MO
fails the house will be in
order we still got a little bit of
business to do the more you cooperate
the quicker we'll get done enjoy the
committee on finance to which was
referred House Bill 1656 FN local an act
relative to adequate education grant
amounts for pupils receiving special
Education Services the city the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation of Bill a
to pass with Amendment sen Tracy MRI for
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following Amendment the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen Mary Jan wner for the
minority of the
committee the motion before us is the
majority committee report which is one
two Amendment which is 121h printed in
house record 14 page 53 are you ready
for the question on the amendment all
those in favor say I iOS
nay the eyes have it and amendment is
adopted B on bills on second reading
open the further Amendment minority
amendment is
13278 printed in house record 14 page
53 Lun recognized to speak and
representative luno is is recognized to
speak to the
amendment thank you very much Mr Speaker
I'm here to speak in support of
amendment 1327 H to House Bill 1656
found on page 53 simple reason is we
need it because it sets the special
education grant to public schools to the
amount recommended by the bipartisan
school funding sub committee and by the
education committee the committee report
printed in House calendar 7 on house for
House Bill 1656 stated in a quote The
increased cost for implementing this
more appropriate funding mechanism is
projected to increase differentiated Aid
by $35 million it's the end of the quote
and on February
22nd this body approved House Bill 1656
at this level by a Voice
vote but when the bill got to finance
the fiscal note was cut in half and
that's not what the special subcommittee
recommended or what the education
committee recommended or what the Full
House
approved the bill without this amendment
doesn't do much to support all public
schools so the legisl legislative budget
assistant office drafted this amendment
to fix it so let's vote Yes on this
amendment a yes vote is good for kids
good for schools and good for local
property
taxpayers thank you Mr Speaker and I do
request a roll
call chair recognized representative
Emer thank you Mr
Speaker this is a very strange
additional Amendment because uh there's
a lot of unknowns in this particular
Bill we don't know we we do know that
the state has approximately
31,000 special education students that's
out of 155,000 so it's about 20% of
students require special ed what the
primary focus of this bill was is to
change what we're currently doing was we
changed anybody with a a special ed
identity gets the same funding what this
B Bill does establish a b and c funding
based on hours of need of particular
students a very good idea we all agree
on it what we don't agree on is how much
we're going to spend right now the
reason for that is the Department of
Education has absolutely no idea how
many a BS and C's rated students there
are so the concept of we got to spend
more for something we don't know about
rather than less
doesn't make a lot of sense so I I'm
opposed to this my Amendment which you
voted on which was also prepared by the
LBA was for approximately $17
million this amendment is for
approximately $35
million so what we're really voting on
is how much do we want to spend on this
particular bill as it's trying to be
implemented that's what this de is about
I hope we you go with the original
Amendment and vote no on this one thank
you Mr Speaker
representative has requested a roll call
is that sufficiently
seconded it is officially seconded
members take your
seats
have
the motion before us is minority
Amendment 1327 H this is going to be a
roll call vote chair recognizes
representative Heath for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
HB
1656 came out of the specials bipartisan
subcommittee recommending $35 million
and Mr Speaker if I know further every
school district struggles with the high
cost of special education would I now
press the green button to assist our
local communities thank you very much Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
wer for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
17 million that the committee assigned
to solve the special ed problem fits
nicely with all the priorities we had to
deal with in the committee's 41 bills
and if I further note that the minority
Amendment will be a major increase in
total spending and will imperil the good
results we've achieved collectively so
far what I now support the 21-4 decision
in this on this first amendment and push
the red button on the Second Amendment
thank
you the motion before us is the
amendment 1327 H this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
was
AAL represent
Barry
while members present have the
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the
vote
187 to
187 the motion
fails the motion before us now is ought
to pass as
amended are you ready for the question
call roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call
vote
e
the motion before is ought to pass as
amended on 1656 it's the roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button the voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend to stay the vote
349 voting a 26 voting a committee
report is
adopted committee on finance to which
was referred House Bill
1666 FN an act relative to incomplete
reporting requirements for lobbyists
having consider the same report the same
with a recommendation to Bill ought to
pass sen Joe Sweeney for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay the
eyes have it and committee report is
adopted committee on finance to which
was referred House Bill
1669 FN in act relative to redistricting
data shared through the state
immunization registry having considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment the recommendation
the bill ought to pass with Amendment s
of Jr H for the committee the amendment
is 1274 printed in house record 14 page
53- 54 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted motion before us
now is a to pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I oppose nay the eyes have
it and the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on finance to
which was referred House Bill 1678 FN
enact establishing a New Hampshire Farm
to school local food incentive pilot
program considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
s of Dan Maguire for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Chuck Grassi for the
minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise uh to place hb1 1678 on the
table the motion is to move uh to uh
report HB 1678 to the
table this is a going to be a division
vote members take your seats
div
the motion before us is to lay House
Bill 1678 on the table this is a
division
vote chair recognizes representative
Osborne for a pentary inquiry thank you
Mr Speaker if I know that this proposal
is duplicative of a program that was uh
accepted last year by the fiscal
committee from the federal government
when I press the green button to table
uh this bill right now thank you chair
recognize representive Simpson for a
parliamentary
inquiry if I know this Bill's already
passed the house once and if I know this
bill supports New Hampshire Farmers
improves food security and strengthens
rural economies and if I know that the
Cooperative agreement mentioned in the
majority report is a short-term program
that ends before the pilot program
begins and finally if I know that that
any school in the state can apply and
one will be chosen from each County
would I now press the red button to
defeat the tabling
motion the motion before us is the table
House Bill 1678 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposer you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
well members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
stay to the
vote 181 voting y 192 voting a the
motion fails we're back to the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate the chair recognizes
representative
Simpson thank you Mr
Speaker hb1 1678 creates a 2-year pilot
program to get more local food into
local schools the pilot program would
encourage schools to spend Federal food
dollars in New Hampshire while taking a
relatively small investment from the
state um as I mentioned in my Pi the
majority report referenced the
collaborative agreement we have now of
federal dollar but that's a short-term
program that's set to come to end before
the PO pilot program would begin and
unlike the collaborative agreement which
is only open to schools with a certain
number of students receiving free and
reduced lunches the pilot program is
open to schools to any school across the
state to apply and at the end of the
pilot program we would have data from
all 10 counties about the feasibility of
a Statewide
program investing in our local and
Regional Food Systems especially our
rural economy makes a big difference in
the economic viability and the
resilience of our small and medium-sized
farms and local communities this bill
represents many years of dedicated time
and energy for stakeholders across the
state those in the Agriculture and food
sectors those in school nutrition
programs and those community members who
are part of the infrastructure that
makes the local food economy Thrive the
Department of Agriculture is willing to
support the program as it would benefit
our farms and our agricultural food
chain local food nourishes children
supports local farmers and strengthens
the res resiliency of our supply chain
there are currently schools across the
state who would like to get involved in
Farm to school program but need
encouragement the pilot program would
allow one District in each of 10
counties to participate schools across
the state can apply to the Department of
Agriculture who will put together a
committee and criteria to choose
participants then the department will
also gather data to discern if and how
to best go about a farm to school
incentive program that would be
accessible in the future to all schools
across the state a couple months ago US
Secretary AR of Agriculture Tom vilsack
spoke here in New Hampshire he described
the many ways that we can support
farming and Rural communities in New
Hampshire one of the ways we can do this
is by investing in our local and
Regional Food Systems the farm to school
program does just that not only can we
help our rural economies but we can also
improve the health and the well-being of
our children and the resiliency of our
local food system the initial pilot
program isn't asking for much let's take
the first step in committing to an
investment in our Farms our fisheries
and our communities thank
you do you recognize representative
Griffin thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I rise in support of
the itl motion on House Bill
1678 this is an unnecessary spending
ending of State
funds this bill is a duplication of a
grant from the federal government only a
few short months ago the fiscal
Committee of this
legislature approved a Federal grant of
$559,000 for an incredibly similar
School Pro found to school
program 1678 raises almost quar a
million of State dollars and duplicates
an existing Federal
grant half of that money is raised in
the fiscal year
2026 which is a next
bium and by doing so it breaks the
unwritten rule that we never encumber a
future legislator
legislature for items that belong in the
next
budget if this project is to go forward
it should be brought to the next budget
session I urge you to press the green
button and it this
bill a division has been requested
members take your
seats sen of who repres requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded members take
your
seats
the motion before us majority committer
report of inexpedient to legisl on house
Bill 1678 this is a roll call vote chair
recognize representative tersi for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill supports New Hampshire
Farmers improves local food security and
builds Community by connecting local
producers and our school districts while
strengthening the agricultural sector
and if I know that this bill also also
help schools so that they have the
ability to easily access healthy local
produce and products even when the
supply chain is threatened and finally
if I know that HB 1678 is simply a pilot
program with moderate funding that
encourages getting locally sourced
nutritious Foods into our schools and
onto the plates of school children would
I now press the red button to overturn
this motion so more appropriate motion
could be made thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize represent wer for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this program is a
duplication of a recent Federal grant
approved by our fiscal committee for
over half a million dollars and if I
know that this bill expends almost a
quar of a million dollars of State money
and if I further know this project and
its funding belong in the next budget
where the success of the half million
project can be assessed along with the
total needs of the state thank you Mr
Speaker and I ask you all to press the
green green
button the motion before us a majority
commit a report of inexpedient to
legisla House Bill 1678 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button of your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
e
all members pres had an opportunity to
vote household tend to say to the
vote 179 voting a 193 voting a the
motion
fails
representative grassy moves ought to
pass are are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I
I suppose
[Music]
nay a a division has been called for
clar for
clarification clarification only any
nobody in nobody
out are you ready for the question now
the motion before us is ought to pass on
1678 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
to vote house attendance stay to the
vote 191 voting a 182 voting a minority
committee report is
adopted
committee on finance to which was
referred Senate Bill 252
FN an act relative to the release of a
defendant pending trial directing the
establishment of an electronic
monitoring program for criminal
defendants released on bail making an
appropriation therefore consider the say
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate pres of Dan Maguire for the
committee for what reason does a member
rise thank you Mr Speaker move to lay SB
252 FN on the
table is a correct motion the motion is
to lay 252 FN on the
table are you ready for the question all
those in favor say
I those oppose
nay eyes have it and House Bill 252 FN
is laid on the
table
Mr
Speaker for what reason the member rise
uh for motion house will be an order St
your motion I'd like to um remove House
Bill 1212 from the
table it's not Dory it is a proper
motion
the motion before us is to remove house
will be in
order is to remove House Bill 1212 from
the table a division has been requested
members take your
seats
C
the motion before us is to move House
Bill 1212 from the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
all members presentent an opportunity to
vote house tend to state to the
vote 185 voting a 188 voting a the
motion
fails without objection the bills
removed from the consent calendar will
be special ordered to their regular
place for the ne in for the next
session for what reason does a member
rise thank you Mr Speaker I would like
to remove 1560 from the
table this will be a division vote so
members take your
seats
you're
the motion before us is to remove 1560
from the
table this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative
Wier for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker colleagues
today we have passed with large bip
parison
support bail
Commissioners disaster
relief Foster children's
placement veterans
court group two retirement
representative I know that we
thing the member will suspend this is a
parliamentary inquiry if I know that we
passed also group two retirement fix at
53 million and I know we also passed
accidental disability retirement and if
I further note none of this can be
funded unless 15 1560 comes off the
table and passes by a two-third majority
because all the money we're relying on
to fund all these things is in the
educational trust fund and it cannot be
used for the items I just brought out
unless it is taken off the table and
passed by a 2/3 so if I know that these
are things that are widely supported by
all of us here today would I now take
1560 off the table and pass it so those
things can be funded by General funds
thank you chair recognize press the
green button press chair recognize
repenter wner for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this house has decided at least two
times that I can remember and maybe more
to put um this bill on the table this
bill is there on the table because we
know we needed the funds in the
education trust fund to uh fund our
obligations to public Ed public
education um would I now vote
no the motion is to remove 1560 from the
table this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press a green button of
your opposer press a red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
repr
shapir
all members present and an opportunity
to vote hous attend to say to the
vote 167 voting aay 204 voting aay the
motion fails chair recogniz chair
recognizes a member from Auburn
represent Osborne for third reading
motion thank you resolve that the house
now adjourned from the early session
that the business of the late session be
in order at the present time that the
reading of bills be by title only and
resolutions by caption only and that all
bills ordered to third reading be read a
third time by this resolution
that all titles of bills be the same as
adopted that they be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today it be to meet at the call of the
chair question is on the third reading
motion are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I close nay you
eyes have
it I have one announcement the
automobile dealers are having their
annual crossover party over the holiday
in I'm assuming it's going on
now
representative Osburn at the house stand
in recess for the purpose of
introduction of build androll bills
Amendment enroll bills report vacation
mode and receiving messages are ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those oppos nay the eyes have
it and the house is in recess to the
call of the
chair
e